after after freezing the GoFundMe for
the freedom truckers twice GoFundMe has
now announced they will no longer allow
any money to come in for the freedom
Convoy and get this they are taking the
money and will work with the organizers
to decide where it should go to a
legitimate charity that they verify
so for everybody who's donated to the to
the truckers make sure you spread the
word to everybody that they're holding
your money and they're going to give it
to it to a charity that they confirm
everybody's saying oh what does that
mean black lives matter yeah probably
maybe not I don't know but you can ask
for a refund they're announcing and give
a refund a lot of people are saying that
this is some people have said it's fraud
because you've given money for a
specific reason and them blocking it as
a third party is interfering in in the
exchange in which case some people have
said do a charge back instead because
you're not getting what you paid for a
refund is is totally different but look
I'm not the uh expert on how all that
will work other than we can see the
statement from GoFundMe they've shut it
down people have switched over to give
send go the trucker movement is growing
and we got a bunch of other really big
news the U.S Freedom Convoy on Facebook
was deleted the group and the person who
set it up was banned from Facebook we've
got statements from you know the the
press the and and and GoFundMe saying oh
it was violent and crimes are being
committed they are scared they are
pathetic they are losing
and so uh just a lot of a lot of big
news around the stuff we've also got get
this today
71 episodes of The Joe Rogan Experience
have been removed from Spotify
I have reached out for comment have not
heard anything so it's it's a story they
did this on Friday I'm not surprised we
can't really figure out why these
particular episodes were pulled Michael
malice tweeted at two of his episodes of
the Rogan Experience are gone but
there's also like uh like Kyle kalinski
got taken down so I wonder if this has
something to do with things that Joe may
have said maybe we'll get answers I kind
of don't think we will but we'll talk
about all of that stuff we got to talk
about the January 6 committee being
devastated according to CNN over Zucker
getting ousted why
because we now know that seeing at the
highest levels and it's not just Cuomo
Chris Cuomo but they were working with
Andrew Cuomo on his entire covid pitch
to become a national figure the
collusion runs deep they know it and now
they're scared they're losing it ladies
and gentlemen it's like that scene in
Starship Troopers when Doogie Howser
puts his hand on the giant bug and goes
it's afraid and everyone cheers that's
what's happening so we're going to talk
about all this joining us today to talk
about all of this and January 6 in the
jails in DC is Special Agent tario
thanks for joining us a special agent I
uh I find that a little offensive you
know special agent no actually I find it
offensive that people call me informant
because after doing two years at
Quantico
it's special agent
they shouldn't lower me to that standard
and now everyone is going home
they're definitely gonna clip that uh
we're I'm joking and and Enrique is
joking but uh Enrique do you want to
introduce yourself uh well my name is
Enrique tario and um I am the former
chairman of The Proud boys as of
Wednesday I've stepped down uh from that
role and uh
I uh got arrested a little bit before uh
January 6 I did uh almost five months in
uh the DC gulag
and
I'm just me
but what we're going to talk about all
that stuff because uh
what it was like in the jail what's
going on with a lot of the January 6
defendants you know the things they said
about you what's just the the this year
is getting crazy man it's gonna get
really crazy it's already crazy it's
it's the beginning of February and we're
already seeing like Joe Rogan getting
episodes pulled we're seeing the freedom
Convoy this year is gonna get lit we
also have Lou gradkowski because Sheamus
got scared and and started crying like
don't worry guys I'm going to keep you
safe from that Irishman anyway I think
it's only going to get crazier this year
and I think it's indicative that a lot
of this major news is breaking on a
Friday the will of the people is being
undermined by some very powerful
despicable entities and uh we're here to
call it out thanks for having me you
want to support me you can by going to
thebestpoliticalshirts.com where you can
get the shirt that I'm wearing right now
that says let's go Brandon that's the
person that I'm going to be voting for
in the next election I'm writing them in
so I hope you do they're going to be
like that that's a Democrat vote that
counts we know what you mean probably
maybe the way that the things have been
going maybe I've been away for a while
but what's this what what is let's go
Brandon mean oh
[Music]
um oh come on it's it's a famous nascar
guy that everyone really likes and he's
running for president uh no no
um he's just a really good NASCAR this
is a great story actually this guy
Brandon was being interviewed by I think
ABC and the crowd was screaming F Joe
Biden And the reporter goes there
yelling let's go Brandon and so there it
is let's go Brandon just means it's a
mean phase I mean that's the state of
things right now yeah yeah basically
it's cloudy dude I'm glad you're hearing
Ricky because I heard that you got
arrested in DC for possessing possession
of a weapon and I find out today from
you fake news it is it is and the way
that that works is
left-wing Outlets will say well he got
caught with a with a firearm with a gun
he was driving across DC independent
Outlets the very small amount of them
that we have oh pick up that story
without comment and then right wing
Outlets will go ahead and they'll write
it too
um but the truth is no I did not get
caught with a with a gun I didn't get
caught with ammo I got caught with what
DC considers to be high capacity
magazines which is your standard 30
round magazines that come with your AR
you know in Florida there is no such
thing as high capacity magazines in
Florida you could buy a drum I could I
could walk around with a magazine in my
hand and nothing happens to be but
across that border into DC it's actually
a felony wow unloaded unloaded unloaded
yeah the piece of it's a piece of
plastic with the spring in it wow yeah
well we'll talk about all that we got
Lydia Preston bug I'm also here in the
corner I was going to say I got very
strong Ralph Northern Vibes when uh
GoFundMe was saying they were going to
set the funds aside and decide what to
do with them later that's a little
sketchy I don't like like that hopefully
get to the bottom of it tonight thievery
yes fraud if you haven't already head
over to timcast.com become a member help
support our show support the work we do
our are all of our journalists are
employed thanks to you guys as members
because membership is what keeps this
whole machine running for the most part
like we do have sponsors and everything
but uh membership really is the the the
the the fuel that allows this engine to
keep on keep on going we have members
only segments of the show Monday through
Thursday at 11 PM so if you want to
check out that massive Library be a
member but go to timcast.com click the
store and pick up your free hunk hunk
t-shirt yes it's not a free t-shirt it's
free Hong Kong like free Hong Kong but
honk honk and it is it's black and red
and it's modeled off of the free Hong
Kong flag so it's got the Canadian Leaf
in there and everything and uh if you
want to support the message of everybody
who's down you know working at
everything and supporting this movement
and I will always say this too if you
really want to support the movement make
sure you're giving to their give send go
and not buying from us if you buy buy
these shirts you're supporting the
message and you're supporting our work
if you really want to support the
truckers and I encourage it go to their
gifts and go because GoFundMe seizing uh
you know their uh their money basically
and go look for these people who are
doing these live streams on the ground
so Viva fry for instance special shout
out he's been on the ground working
really really hard doing amazing live
streams I I supported him earlier you
guys can support him as well many people
have shouted out Portland Andy I'm not
familiar with Portland Portland Andy but
anybody on the ground covering this
breaking through the lies of the
mainstream media which we're going to
show you I I want to give a special
shout out to all you know these people
and I'm sure there's many many more mind
to you but those are the ones that I
mostly know about let's get into this
first massive story I could not believe
it I mean honestly I could believe it
it's just crazy GoFundMe post it on
medium their statement on the freedom
Convoy they say GoFundMe supports
peaceful protests and we believe that
was the intention of the freedom Convoy
fundraiser when it first started we now
have evidence from law enforcement at
the previously peaceful demonstration
has become an occupation with police
reports of violence and other unlawful
activity
when was occupational occupy protests
considered to be violent or not allowed
I seem to recall the uh the Chas the
chop Chas the autonomous zones what
about the autonomous Zone in Minneapolis
did they shut down any of that stuff no
black lives matter and these and
antifone these groups are still
fundraising and making money surprise
surprise they say to ensure GoFundMe
remains a trusted platform we work with
local authorities to ensure we have a
detailed factual understanding of events
taking place on the ground uh let me
just tell you this GoFundMe you you have
lost all trust well you lost your trust
a long time ago as far as I'm concerned
I can't believe anyone would have used
to GoFundMe at this point if you you
here's what you do tell each and every
person you know passively just be like
oh GoFundMe nah they're bad don't use
them just they're really really awful
use Gibson go here's what's important
though they say
given how the situation has evolved no
further funds will be directly
distributed to the freedom Convoy
organizers we will work with organizers
to send all remaining funds to Credible
and established Charities verified by
GoFundMe all donors May submit a request
for a full refund until February 19th
2022 using this dedicated refund form
well I'll say this if GoFundMe is like a
payment processor and they intercept
your funds that was supposed to go to
someone I don't know if maybe they've
got things in their service like we're
allowed to do this whatever I assume
they are because they hold the money
first and then transfer it but this
seems like there's some kind of you know
deceptive practice here that they do to
take money from you if I say Luke I
would like to buy some of your mental
Jewels or whatever the hell that thing
is and you say okay and then Ian takes
my money and says no I'm gonna give it
to Lydia instead I'd be like wait what
yeah how do you do that hey Ian give me
give Luke this 20 for me I'm going to
buy those Jewels I'll be like yeah sure
Tim and as I this one I'm like hey Lydia
can I buy that coffee you're hearing for
20 bucks yeah I'm gonna give you 20. and
then they come to you why didn't you ask
for a refund and I'll be like dude I was
sitting here waiting for Luke's mental
Jewels what is that this is uh Mark
actually Mark loben actually gave me
these uh sent me this and a whole bunch
of other supplies
yeah yes uh definitely read them make
sure you're not like alert I look over
at whatever Luke's got on his side I got
a whole bunch of drinks
there's gotta be there's gotta be
something that the SEC can do there
um
I mean they've cracked down before on
like gofundme's like if I started
GoFundMe and I said hey I'm going to use
it for x and I use it for y
um I know that that's highly illegal
right but for GoFundMe to do it I think
that that that goes into the SEC
territory yeah they they they they
should not be able to reappropriate
funds but I'm sure they have in their
terms I'm pretty sure they do that if
something happens in the the the the
project or whatever fundraiser is shut
down then they take the money I'm pretty
sure GoFundMe does say that they
shouldn't be allowed to do that period
though if I say you know I want to give
this money to a cause they should not be
allowed to reappropriate it it should
just go back automatically refund well
GoFundMe has been becoming increasingly
political and this move is just
absolutely absurd this is theft this is
people being robbed of their money that
they wanted for specific cause then
they're going to be redistributing it
for causes that they believe in that
they align with which most likely
probably is going to be Marxist leftist
ideas and organizations Robert Barr
turns a very prominent lawyer who was on
this broadcast before said that this is
fraud and there's grounds for a class
action lawsuit here since of course
again how can you say that this is not
political especially when GoFundMe has
been used in so many different political
ways especially when people were
punished and attacked whenever they go
against the establishment on GoFundMe
there is more than enough evidence to
show you that this is a hyper partisan
organization that is not there to raise
funds for any charity they are there for
power they are there for a political
cause and nothing else and they will
stop anything stopping in their way
including good people who want to give
their money so if you go to give send
go.com you will likely encounter a
crashed website because everybody's
rushing over there to support the
truckers I don't know exactly what the
official uh fundraiser is there is one
on the front page trending it says adopt
a trucker and it's they've raised 213
827 Canadian dollars from 2178 people
when I try to go to it unfortunately
it's just crashed so and there's another
thing to consider here because you know
this Tim and I know this as well because
I've been running my own online business
whenever you email all of your customers
there's a percentage that of course
never get the message whether it's an
email whether it's a direct message
whether even if it's a message on your
own platform there's going to be a
number of people that never hear about
this notification never open that email
and their money is going to go to
whatever political cause GoFundMe wants
to give so there's going to be a lot of
money here that gets redistributed in a
way that it's absolutely bastardized and
disgusting a majority of people aren't
going to know this happen exactly that's
what I that's that's what I'm saying
um and and it's not going to be you know
a small fraction it's going to be a
significant portion because whenever I
try to send out messages to to my
members it's only a small small portion
that actually do open the email do
actually read all the latest updates and
important things that they need to know
Tim let me ask you I mean I haven't
really been keeping up with this but did
you say that they have to fill out a
refund form yeah in order to get the
money back well I'm going to suggest
something anybody that's listening to
this show
um instead of filling out that credit
card process I mean that refund form
what they need to do is they need to
call in uh their bank and do a
chargeback right
um
because there I don't think there's
anybody if it's a credit card though
right if it's a credit or debit card it
doesn't matter yeah they could you could
you could you could do a chargeback
um because it's really it's service is
not rendered you're you're paying for a
service so I could give money to the
truckers but then they're going to give
it to like some other cause
um some other virtue signal they cause
that for sure you don't you will never
give money to
um I don't think there's many people
that know about the credit card industry
as much as I do uh and the reason why I
tell you that because I've been banned
off of everything and I've had to find
new ways
um to to process payments on my
1776.shop and one of the tactics was was
that they they'd go ahead and they'd get
chargebacks in order for the credit card
money yeah it costs it cost me 35 each
time they do it wow so if they pay
twenty one dollars if they pay twenty
one dollars for a shirt they're going to
refund 21 and then you're gonna have to
pay 35 it's kind of like a an overdraft
fee kind of thing there's also I
remember when I think it was patreon
when they banned I think I think it was
Owen Benjamin
he said go he wanted to go to
arbitration or whatever and every single
person who got shut down because patreon
basically interfered with like several
hundred people or a thousand people and
him all of them could file arbitration
and then patreon was panicking because
that would mean they'd have to front the
cost of arbitration so it was like
millions of dollars I don't exactly
remember what happened with that but yo
there's 10 million dollars Canadian
there's like eight million U.S I don't
know how many people donated probably
tens of thousands but I don't I don't
know if they could handle if that's you
know tens of thousands it could cost a
million bucks or more it could cost them
theoretically around 8 million dollars
if everyone did a chargeback yeah and we
should also kind of speculate why this
is happening is GoFundMe just doing this
because they don't politically align
with the people in Canada with the
truckers or is the Canadian government
and other powerful forces whether
multinational or big banking coming to
them and saying hey you got to get rid
of these people or we're going to shut
you down or we're going to make sure you
can't operate your business because this
is a huge setback for GoFundMe there is
no logical business reason for them to
do this because they are shooting
themselves in the foot and isolating a
huge public from ever using their
platform ever again I'm never going to
use GoFundMe I did use them a couple
years ago never again in my life will I
ever be using them uh because of just
how blatantly political this is why did
this happen I think there was probably
speculating here pressure from the
Canadian government saying get rid of
this we need to stop the funding we need
to stop these protests we need to stop
the voices of the people in Canada
immediately so but one of my questions
is and
I want to be fair here like what did
these truckers do did these truckers
like do they are they slamming their
trucks into something are they are they
do they got like Nazi flags are they
calling for the government to be
overthrown let's let's we got to be fair
okay you know we got to be fair and call
it out when it needs to be called out
these truckers they did honk their horns
they did Hong Kong and you know that is
a capital offense I mean that's that's
you know off with their heads so so says
the queen I mean I'm kidding by the way
they they did nothing I mean it's a
bunch of guys and trucks yeah but but
just even a few days ago we had the
Ottawa city councilor uh come out and
she demanded that GoFundMe stop this
particular fundraising event because it
was quote according to her a pipeline of
funding to unlawful mercenaries this is
the language of an Ottawa city councilor
literally making public statements
demanding a private company stop the
voices of the people
and that to me is for sure it looks like
GoFundMe got political pressure you guys
if not from the stripe payment system or
the the Swift payment system that's
right it's weird that the stripe and
Swift are so similar but Swift is the
big one I'll tell you the situation here
and it doesn't have to do with like
their credit card processor they're
working they're working in Tandem and as
far as their views go I can tell you
like this problem that we're talking
about today
we knew about this problem three years
ago
um the first time I used GoFundMe where
my GoFundMe got shut down was during the
events of hurricane Harvey in 2017 uh
our funding goal it was for to do direct
water rescues and we're only asking for
like a thousand bucks we raised like
twelve hundred dollars we passed the
limit and uh they froze the account they
never gave the money
um because it just had the the proud boy
name on it it wasn't because it wasn't
because uh of anything to do with
anything else anything nefarious or
anything like that so I've been
screaming about GoFundMe for a long time
give sengo has been an excellent
platform
um
I uh but they were I knew I know that
they changed their credit card processor
because they were using stripe system
and they wanted to keep like funding
like some of these j6 political
prisoners they wanted to keep funding
like their their uh their campaigns but
the problem is that stripe called them
and Stripes said if you don't stop doing
business if you don't shut down this
campaign we're cutting you off you
stripe did yeah not Swift uh no they
were using stripe at the top wow and you
know as a business owner you know
they have to continue to work so they
had no choice but to shut it down they
changed after that they changed their
credit card processor and uh it's been
chill
um there's another company by the name
of our freedom funding
that did the opposite so they're like oh
we could we could fund all your causes
and um as a matter of fact they they
stole 85 000 from my family fund right
from my family it wasn't like my fund
um and then from Joe biggs's defense
fund I think they stole a grand total
out of seventy thousand dollars they
stole about like thirty five thousand
dollars out of his funding campaign so
like you have nowhere to go you have no
representation right you have no money
and the this guy comes out of the blue
and is like I got this website that you
could that you could fundraise on and
then he steals your money yeah that's my
problem with non-centralized donation
Services is they're insecure if some
like Craigslist you know good luck
trying to do anything with any oversight
like at least with give send go or
GoFundMe you've got some sort of
recourse to get your money back I I kind
of want to bring it back to the truckers
because I think we have to examine what
did these truckers do
I can tell you I can tell you actually
we have the story from Global News
Canada a few nights ago we read the
Toronto Sun that claimed the truckers
Were Far Right racists you know Nazis
who stole food from the homeless I kid
you not check this one out Security
Experts concerned about possible threat
financing tied to trucker Convoy what
they say Canadians ought to be worried
about whether crowdfunding websites
could be used to finance hate groups and
other extremist organizations Financial
crime and Security Experts warn as the
so-called Freedom Convoy enters its
second week of protests in Ottawa hard
questions are being asked about a
GoFundMe campaign set up by Convoy
organizers and whether any of the 10
million dollars raised so far might have
come from malevolent sources keen on
wreaking havoc in Canada Security
Experts also say they're worried about
the lack of transparency surrounding the
fundraiser and whether any of the
donations could end up in the hands of
hate groups or people who promote
hateful ideologies including people who
attended the protests carrying Nazi
flags and the flags of known terrorist
groups oh heavens well they basically
let me read this quote the way that
we're sort of talking about this now
this event is sort of like an extremism
event so I would argue that this sort of
a component of extremism financing this
is said Jessica Davis a financial crimes
expert and president of insight Insight
threat intelligence yo Working Class
People standing up against tyrannical
government are being called terrorists
Ian you're saying about 9 11. Jessica
Davis is like it's sort of like a sort
of a thing sort of so no it's not you're
saying actually but but this is such
slander such vicious destruction of of
the truth there was like I think one or
two guys with some weird Flags they got
kicked out of a rally when they were
there by the protesters these are blue
collar individuals realizing that the
entire system collapses without their
participation and they're being vilified
they're getting attacked on on things
that they have never done and and it's
just mind-boggling to see this this huge
full frontal assault with blue collar
people representing the will of the
people there's new poll numbers coming
out from Canada specifically
highlighting how the majority of people
in Canada want to get rid of all
restrictions so far as of today Denmark
Finland Norway the Czech Republic the
United Kingdom dropped all of their
coveted lockdowns and restrictions
Canada wants to do the same things the
people there want that same thing the
truckers there are trying to push those
policies and the government instead of
hearing out the people meeting them
halfway seeing what they actually want
they're just calling them racists and
and attacking them on things that have
absolutely no merit at all which is just
disgusting absolutely disgusting
Behavior it's disturbing no merit in
Truth at all I knew they could do this
this weird slander thing but I didn't
know I didn't know when I was like 25 or
30 how intense and Relentless it could
be and how they just keep using the word
terrorists uh extremists what are these
other words they were using in the in
the reasons for canceling this stuff uh
they use these buzzwords uh hate hates
another one they use these words hate
groups hate so it's just pure fascist
manipulation it's they're losing I know
it's but it's what do they do when
they're losing it's like a Super Saiyan
yeah you got to watch out that they
don't say super saiyan watch out that
these crazy militaries don't go insane
because they think they're losing they
are losing they are losing the best
strategic win uh that's come from this
trucker Convoy and it's not it's not
really the protest I think the Strategic
win for them is how the government's
reacting to their protest it's not what
they're doing because I mean I I'm a
person that believes that things got to
get a lot worse before they get better
and there hasn't been and again I
haven't really been keeping up with this
I've heard but
to date there hasn't been a clear uh
a clear way where the government you
could see the government's overreach
than we're seeing with the Canadian
trucker thing we've seen this here and
but when it comes to when it comes to
Canada we're seeing like this
manipulation of not only the media the
government that city council that says
that they're mercenaries that's where
the real win is it's the exposure that
the Canadian government uh is is is
getting from it yeah I agree it's the
first time I've ever seen the Canadian
government uh completely oblivious and
ignorant of its populace that's usually
government always from my perspective
from the way I've been seeing them uh
but but you know this is not a surprise
here but but this also speaks to the
true power that these truckers have and
what kind of threat they are to the
establishment that they're pulling out
all these stops all these incredible
stealing people's money to like like
so I was on Reddit earlier I'm gonna
read it all the time I'm just browsing
through it and it's a it's a leftist
propaganda machine don't get me wrong
and I saw this image this image this is
from George alexopoulos we have several
of we have a bunch of his art up on the
walls here in the studio because he's
incredible and he has this really really
great he's been doing these satirical
cartoons mocking the mainstream media
and this one shows a trucker Convoy but
the trucks are wearing Clan hoods and
and with Ticky torches or something and
there's a sign that says fascism like
fascism but it's spelled wrong and then
it says like oh 106 miles
so he's clearly mocking how the media is
going after the truckers this was on
Reddit on r slash picks and I thought it
was hilarious because it was getting
upvoted to the top of the page like
people were actually I think it's
because they use Bots to upvote leftist
propaganda but whoever put it in didn't
realize he was making fun of them and
all the comments were like this is the
stupidest thing I've ever seen I don't
understand they spelled fascism wrong
the truckers aren't fascists all of the
comments were like this is a worker's
Uprising these are regular people and I
was like whoa dude why are the
commenters like not part of the
propaganda machine like they're they're
they they realized what was going on in
the lies I guess they removed the post
maybe once they realized it was making
fun of the mainstream media but to see
the comments on Reddit understand this
is this is a bunk idea and the truckers
are good and they're hard-working people
standing up for their rights that was
kind of surprising
absolutely and when you see the larger
kind of implications here there's no
demands by the truckers that have
anything to do with any kind of larger
political ideology instead it's it's all
about getting rid of the restrictions
the lockdowns the vax mandates and
specifically the Border restrictions
which would hinder and disrupt the
global supply chain why is Canada
implementing a vax passport system on
the border disrupting the global supply
chain more than it already is disrupted
it's a it's a situation that has
absolutely no merit no science behind it
no data people realize it's bunk it's
idiotic the UK government and many other
governments are not following any of
this bull crap anymore and the people
there are saying we're just sick of it
we're done with it we want our lives to
return to normal that's what they're
asking for they're not left they're not
right I haven't seen any major kind of
larger political ideologies other than
stop with this nonsense stop trying to
control Our Lives that's all I've seen
yeah I saw one report the truckers are
saying they'll I'll stay until May yeah
they'll just they'll just hang out and
burn and these people that are claiming
they're like keeping up at night
apparently that's not true I was
listening to Viva Fry's live stream and
he went around talking to people and
they said they stopped blowing their
horns around 10 p.m because the truckers
realize they're not protesting people
and so he basically just said that
they're just they stop around 10 and
then the the assumption is yeah the
truckers don't want to piss off regular
people but they're putting out these
lies to the best of their abilities and
then you look at you these social media
platforms and they're actually arguing
that working-class people rising Up
Against the Machine are the fascists
dude it's not working anymore CNN the
implosion The Narrative the lies it's
kind of crazy because this is an
election year
last year was kind of chill because it
really wasn't there were some elections
and now in the first in the first month
we get swatted twice right we're getting
we're getting cyber attacks and now
you've got the popular this this
populist Uprising and the establishment
just goes nuclear and destroys instantly
all their credibility like their
credibility evaporated so quickly among
regular people I was surprised to see it
so you're big on having law enforcement
in studio huh what do you mean with
getting swatted well they we they came
in the first not bringing me on what was
that they're now bringing me on well you
know that I think they swatted us
because of Marjorie Taylor green but I'm
like I don't care like we're gonna have
her back she came on the show yeah and
we're gonna have around it it's
insightful
that's see that's what they're mad about
that's what they're mad about because
she explains how these people in
Congress don't actually do their jobs
they just leave and like they don't know
but no one even votes they do like just
they uh they say yay or nay and they
sound so similar the words yay sounds so
similar so it's like I can't wait to do
this joke I'm gonna do it it's gonna be
so good okay everyone in favor yay
everyone against hey the is have it and
then the best bang it nobody knows who
passes they vote with their voice dude
in Congress maybe you already know that
no no no but it's not just that it's
like there's only 10 people she's like
there's only 10 people sitting there
going like uh okay next next and they're
just approving and sliding things
through that they never even read yep
and they're making things into law
affecting people's lives destroying
their livelihoods destroying their
existence giving us more bureaucracy
with something that they don't even
understand that special interest
literally right up for them give it to
them and they just pass it on through
and make it law that's how Allah is made
special interest literally just create
their own rules that's the laws we're
living under especially with what
GoFundMe just did right now I think
there's also a reason that they did this
on a Friday evening uh because obviously
people are tuned out people aren't
paying attention people are out trying
to go out and have a drink and party and
relax and forget about the work week and
I think they're trying to you know make
sure that this doesn't get a lot of
attention but
freaking yo I just I just wanna just to
say this if you're not following George
alexopoulos on Instagram you need to
follow G Prime 85 on Instagram because
he gets his he gets his art pulled off
of Instagram every so often and his
jokes are just 10 out of 10 and I can't
even I can't even show you some of them
because they're they're they're edgy
they're really funny it's really really
great so G Prime 85 G Prime 85 we
actually have his uh art with like Joe
Biden using the Force lightning and
vaporizing a crowd of people it's just
really really I saw that picture of the
trucker Convoy that with the KKK helmet
on or whatever and I was like oh what is
this trash propaganda and then I looked
down and I saw G Prime I was like yeah
that's what I thought it was when you
guys pulled me he's got he's got he's
got another one I I don't think I can I
was thinking about showing it I can't
that one's spicy it's good but I gotta
say his latest drawing I think may be
his greatest work yet yes and it's about
the truckers and I saw people tweeting
it not realizing he was making fun of of
the media and I was laughing for like 20
minutes straight that's how good it is
and it's so offensive that YouTube
probably won't allow us to show it
that's so I you follow G Prime 85
seriously it's it's that good but let's
talk about what's happening here in the
United States we got this from the New
York Post
Facebook removes Freedom Convoy page of
truckers against Vex mandates they say
a protest to organize a Facebook page
organizing a protest of U.S truckers
against mandates has been removed and
and you know what Facebook said
the group's Convoy to DC 2022 was
removed Wednesday for violating policies
around Q Anon what
remember when Julie Kelly was here and
she was like wait until they claim Q
anon's there oh yeah they're doing it
two minutes ago she nailed it she was
ahead of the curve on that one so um U.S
truckers want to do a convoy they want
to go I think it's from like West Coast
to DC we're really close to DC so we
would be we would have people on the
ground covering it if it were to happen
and Facebook shuts it down they ban the
guy who uh this is what it was reported
the guy who set it up just a regular
Facebook profile it banned him too they
really do not want this to keep
happening it is like it's like Occupy
Wall Street but like for real yeah you
know what I mean yeah well I mean astro
turf Lefty garbage well in the beginning
uh it represented an idea that unified
the left and the right and people who
just wanted accountability from the
banking system that was truly
controlling our way of lives especially
after the 2008 financial crisis but this
also represents another major time in
our existence where a lot of people are
realizing that they were conned that
they were relied about that they were
screwed over and they want some
accountability they want some justice
they want their lives to have some kind
of normalcy and have a semblance of it
and I think truckers are the backbone of
of many countries including in this
country they're realizing it and
understanding that they have Collective
power this idea has caught on in
Australia it has caught on in Holland it
has caught on in some ways here in the
United States but it's being stifled so
this idea doesn't grow as of course the
big Tech corporate monopolies are making
sure that this idea is constrained and
of course doesn't expand to the point
where it has expanded in Canada where
they have already done many actions that
have led to a significant conversation
that the establishment does not want to
have right now this is a crazy year
already man yeah you know what I want to
do you know you know you know what I'm
imagining in my head as Luke's talking
I'm just thinking about
Chicago on a warm spring evening
I'm in a nice like second floor
apartment
walk over the couch turn on the TV put
on a movie where friends are all there
we order a pizza and some wings and
we're sitting there and we're talking
about nonsense just having a laugh and
you know it's the way things used to be
back in the day and now it's just you
know it's so chaotic yeah everything is
politics everything is is conflict it's
getting crazier there's no moment where
you just turn on a show and try and I
mean there's these little moments here
and there I was watching Batman earlier
just trying to like just get away from
everything but I saw uh as I browse
Reddit again there's a subreddit called
non-political Twitter because our
culture has pop culture is just politics
at this point it is everything are there
like five tweets there yeah and they're
like I found them finally yeah yeah
probably five individuals just being
like hi the weather's okay everything's
even the weather is becoming political
especially in Texas especially with our
energy and infrastructure policies in
Texas so it's the apocalypse they're
like Ted Cruz is tweeting about Cancun
again and it's like and every day is a
major news day every day something
significant happens to the point where
if you even tune out for two weeks you
will be totally lost and not
understanding of what's really happening
in our modern society could you imagine
going to jail for like four months
I was about to tell you guys while I was
in there all I had was like an RSS feed
to like CNN that's it the Fox News RSS
that's bad the Fox News RSS feed just
doesn't work it's just a blank page and
I missed so much like everybody came out
and they're like hey did you hear about
this did you hear about that and it's
it's overwhelming to try to catch up to
it you know I'm trying for for since
January and I know we're going to get
into that a little bit later since
January you know I eat sleep and breathe
like j6 cases I'd listen into all the
court cases take a look at all the
arguments and now just to catch up it's
impossible it's overwhelming like I get
home and I'm like okay I'm gonna read
about this and I'm like you know what
I'm not I'm just gonna disconnect and
I'm just gonna relax did you have access
to information while you were in jail
just to see in an RSS feedback so
basically just nothing news yeah nothing
I had three I had three forms of uh to
read the media the news the RSS feed
from CNN I'd we'd get the Washington
Post and then there's this local DC
newspaper that would it was we I'm sorry
it's weekly uh DC newspaper and two of
the pages two out of the ten Pages were
written by Louis Farrakhan what I have
it I have it I'll send you guys a
picture and that was the only way that
you got news I I I'm imagining this and
I'm like
trying to trying to get news in your
circumstance would be akin to like
crawling through the desert starving and
someone comes with a big basket of fruit
and you're like oh thank you and you
bite into it it's wax yeah so I guess
not even food that's CNN I'll be honest
it was
it was a little refreshing you know it
was a little refreshing to like
not be locked in that 23 hour in one
Gulag but it was refreshing to where I'm
not like constantly
worried about the state of the country
like I'm in the worst part in the of of
the country and I was only there for a
short time uh but if if the only media
you could consume in there is that you
know
um and then the education program what
was that like oh dude again we'll get
into that a little later was it like
woke no super woke it was it was just
and I I I wrote down uh I broke down the
entire curriculum for the education
program by bias uh by
um biographies uh and I'll tell you
about that a little bit later but yeah
there's a huge huge bias it's it's it's
it's a machine it's a gulag bro well so
this is why Facebook nukes uh the
organizers but here's what I want to say
about that
you know I'm actually kind of grateful
that Our Generations Elites are some of
the stupidest mother
efforts you know ever
because if we had like actually
competent Elites they'd be manipulating
controlling everything and you wouldn't
even notice but these are like the
grandkids of the you know they've
inherited this world as the Elites from
the past generations and they're just
really really dumb it's like the inbred
royalty they're just like like too
stupid to realize what's going on and so
they're like what do we do they're
organizing again quick ban their profile
and they ban it and then now we're
talking about it now everyone it's dry
sand affecting they didn't know that was
gonna happen so my only thought process
is like they can't be that dumb can they
unless unless
it's on purpose they wanted the Convoy
to get more attention so they banned it
on purpose that way we talk about it and
it gets bigger but I can't believe that
it's just I don't think they're that
smart I think they're really dumb people
yeah I think you're right I think
there's some gymnastics to
to really
get that going I I mean I think there's
an effort to try to conceal everything
that's why this was done on a Friday I
think there are a lot of really dumb ass
individuals that are put into positions
of power especially inside of the
government but I also think there is a
super intelligent uh kind of elitist
group that do uh you know arrange a lot
of these zombies into a position that
benefits them greatly at the cost of
everyone else so I I think you know
what's happening right now it's really
hard to quantify in many elements
because things are moving so fast and so
rapidly it's hard to even get a
consensus of exactly what's going on
here but uh it wouldn't surprise me if
these were uncalculated desperate moves
made by desperate individuals who are
who have a lot of people losing faith in
them a lot of people are saying I don't
trust the government the government lied
to me the government screwed me over the
government locked me down the government
took away my job the government took
away my social life the government took
away my form of existence the government
wants me in a pod eating bugs on VR our
virtual reality and I don't want to live
in that kind of life where I have no
privacy I don't own anything I'm
allegedly going to be happy no I don't
want that VR wait wait wait we are
in my box
you're saying you don't want to live in
the pot and eat the bugs no what are you
a racist that's that's the talking
points that we're probably gonna be
hearing in a few days uh could you would
you be allowed to have an Oculus when
you were in jail would they give you one
Jesus Jesus no it was it was an
educational tablet with like Trump man
bad how he's killed democracy how the uh
I can't say it on the show but uh about
that about vaccines about the election
and things like that uh very very Gulag
bro yeah you're literally a Google
re-educated it was really hard not to
get programmed it was really really hard
not to get programmed would they ask you
to like repeat what you were reading
like now tell us the things that we had
you read I should have brought it I have
I have a uh in the education program
they gave me like a piece of paperwork
to do and it said uh how to identify
your unconscious bias wow that was that
was the entire and again I'll send you
guys the yeah that's like re-education
yeah yeah and that's the only that's the
only media that you could consume were
you alone were you like in isolation or
um yeah for the most part I was in
isolation for the first three months
then uh the U.S Marshals had come in and
did like that whole press release
um about the conditions being unlivable
and uh I fired the alarms on that I went
to court and then after I went to court
they rolled out the red carpet they they
sent me to like this unit and but I was
only
I was only out of the isolation for
about 10 days before
guess what came by
Joe Biden Omicron oh and then what
omnicron 23-1 again back to ISO when
you're talking isolation is that
literally it's you alone in a small room
you alone in a small room for 23 hours a
day uh and towards December they pushed
it even more where they'd only let you
out for 15 minutes a day just to take a
shower and come back in in you have a
like a light bulb one light bulb or
something yeah a light bulb and then
yeah wow I got books yeah and here's the
thing like I'm I'm thankful that I have
such a great family and such a great
support system people would send me
books but there's a lot of people that
didn't have books with these people in
their knowledge for j6 are they can
people send them stuff yes you guys
could send them uh books they have to be
through a certain process like Barnes
and Noble through the USPS system
um and certain books will get yeah you
can send them letters but they get the
letters here's the thing uh it was
January and I was getting mail from
September so it's a hit or miss
sometimes it'll take three weeks
sometimes it'll take four months I wanna
I wanna give uh this whole story like
from start to finish its own opportunity
so let's let's talk about what's going
on in media and then we'll we'll make
our way to the full story of what's
going on with j6 and everything we have
this tweet from Michael malice check
this out because we're just talking
about Facebook censorship so in in light
of that we have Michael malice tweeting
Spotify has deleted two of my Joe Rogan
appearances Michael did Spotify delete
it
did Joe delete it we don't know he says
both of the episodes are pre-covered
this website checks for you so if you
head over to jremissing.com you can see
right right right at the top Gad said
gone Mike Ward and pintellus gone
Michael malice Kyle Kolinski Tom Segura
Michael malice Theo Von Peter Holmes
wherever it says new there are 71
episodes that have been removed TJ Kirk
Aubry Marcus was a Theo Von one recent
the Theo Von is uh not no I don't think
so it's 9 20. there are two then there's
there's more reason from 11 41 actually
yeah so he had a recent one pulled too
well it was about a year relatively
recent like like Gad said was you know
240 episodes ago so this is quite some
time ago like a year plus but you can
see all of these are removed on the
fourth Spotify
has removed these episodes I think it's
fair to say but the question is why have
they removed them the point I was making
about Michael malice's did Joe agree
with these removals did he disagree with
them why are they removed and the so far
113 episodes have been taken down now
this is Joe Rogan's show he can do
whatever he wants with it right if he
wants to get an episode Down fine
here's here's the challenge it's kind of
strange that there are there's a website
dedicated to tracking episodes of some
dude's podcast
but the issue is as I was talking about
earlier the whole world is just conflict
everything pop culture is conflict now I
just want to curl up on the couch put on
some you know DC show or movie watch
Batman fight the Joker have some pizza
and then wake up in the morning and go
just walk around maybe go to restaurant
with some pancakes but you can't do that
anymore because you turn on the TV
everything's politics everyone is
politics everything everything so what's
happening is Joe Rogan has become
effectively you know at the tip of the
spear one of the most important cultural
information centers and it's not about
him telling you facts and stuff like
that's about him having conversations
that allow regular people to kind of
understand the world so when Spotify
bends the knee or Joe does to the woke
mob who won't let up
as I've already stated
when they when they announced the
misinformation policy and they gave a
grain of sand they're continually giving
ground to the left the left will not
stop what happens next the next day we
get announcement oh this podcast is
pulling Obama saying he's not going to
do anything anymore he's they're angry
the prince you know will who is it
Prince William and Megan what's her face
they're like we're not going to make a
podcast either even though they haven't
and I'm like and then Crosby Stills and
Nash and I'm like giving them what they
ask for doesn't make them stop now
Spotify has pulled 71 more episodes
maybe it was Joe who pulled them
regardless it's not going to make them
stop yeah you don't concede to the
demands of delusional idiotic crazy
people who just want to censor speech
and a lot of people don't just see this
as a podcast they see this as a last
stand for free speech and with these
latest developments I mean this is this
is troubling this website was started
because originally when Joe Rogan moved
from YouTube to Spotify there was
allegedly an error that was happening
with some of the more controversial uh
videos that and in interviews that
didn't Port over Joe Rogan made a
statement about this said that they
would Port over they never did there's
this website now there's more videos
that are gone memory hold and no longer
in existence and people are left with
some very serious questions that I think
we should have some answers to now again
probably Joe Rogan is going through in a
tremendous amount of pressure
um I could only imagine when he's going
through behind the scenes of things that
we don't even know so what's really
happening here I don't know but it's a
troubling development especially when 71
videos
why these episodes it's a bunch of his
friends I think it's because he doesn't
want to implicate them in the drama I
know
Michael Mouse has several appearances I
think he has four only two get removed
yeah but but this is ours and and hold
on a minute if that were true he didn't
remove any of my episodes is he trying
to get me in trouble you're not dramatic
you're so smooth and cool but I mean
it's it's a lot of it's a lot of
episodes episodes at 71 I think I
honestly think that this woke mob has
been satisfied with taking down 71
episodes it's a lot I don't think so I
think it's only the beginning no no I
think it's a taste it's a taste of blood
and they want their whole enchilada he
didn't take down Dr Robert Malone no he
took down Gad sad and Michael malice and
Kyle Kolinski yeah and Sam and Sam
tripley Brian Redbrand uh Ari shafir no
I wonder I wonder if this has more to do
with what Joe said on those shows as
opposed to what the guests said no
definitely it is uh and and here's the
thing I was joking about that the thing
is that their target isn't Joe Rogan
episode number 1000. it's Joe Rogan that
they want to take out period right and I
mean so many this is like we're so
behind the curve on this like we've been
screaming this and I get why people
don't like the proud boys I completely
understand and I respect their decision
not to like us I get it but once they
took Alex down then they took us down
right and they took down everybody in
between
uh
they're just not gonna stop and I think
we're getting to that point
where they're banning they're banning
the truckers on the other front they're
banning the truckers now and before that
they banned Alex Jones The Proud boys
and everybody else in between were
getting to the point where it's getting
so extreme that there's conversions
coming from this because regular
truckers are that probably aren't
political now they're like okay they're
against my people now I'm gonna go uh to
the Capitol you know I think I know what
this is
when you go to jremessing.com you can
see a big a big portion of all the new
ones it's it's when you get to the top
they start spacing themselves out like
963-925 there's a big gap of almost 40
episodes there then 912 then 100
episodes 8 10 to the next one right yeah
but you go down to the beginning and
it's like 4 20 21 27 40 42 48 50 55 57
66 72 that's back in the crude days when
they say whatever was saying whatever
saying like there's a compilation people
have put out of him saying the n word
not using it saying it there's
compilations people have made of him
saying offensive things I wonder if
these episodes getting pulled are
because Joe himself had said things that
crossed the line or are today no longer
consider politically correct yeah but
even deleting them brings more attention
to these videos like I think he's smart
enough to understand unless this was
Spotify that did this but I think he's
smart enough to understand that if you
if you try to take something off of the
internet and hide it from the general
public people are going to go crazy and
then talk about it even more and obsess
about it because of that that aspect of
getting rid of it so that you know
everything's on on the on the Internet
is almost permanent especially when you
try to hide it and you have the
Streisand Effect to take place but
here's a consequence with that is from
now on it's it's getting watered down
and watered down and by the time that
you know it you're going to get a
completely watered-down JRE podcast that
is like you're not even going to
recognize it anymore people mention this
when the first when the shift happened
when Joe first moved over to Spotify
there were some questions about whether
or not he was going to be edgier or
softer and a lot of people thought he
was going soft because then he started
doing these big celebrity interviews he
did I think like Miley Cyrus and he had
like Robert Downey Jr but he had on
Peter McCullough and Dr Robert Malone
he's had on Alex Jones I I don't think
he's gone soft at all however with this
latest massive move it's been a
month-long campaign against him and they
now pull 71 episodes when those when
that shift happened from YouTube to
Spotify the official statement we got I
think I think what Joe said was that
YouTube didn't archive a bunch of the
shows properly and he couldn't download
them that's that happens that that's
happened to us on several occasions when
you go into your YouTube manager you can
take a stream and click download and for
some reason some of them just can't do
it what you can do though is you can do
a hard record you can play the video and
then just screen record the whole thing
and capture it if you had to if you had
to there's probably other there's
probably other programs you can get
those programs it's harder on live
streams you can't you can't just use
like the Auto download video thing for
them for some of them but we were told
they would get put back up they never
got put back up this is different this
is this is a sustained uh campaign
against Joe and then on one day on a
Friday evening all at the same time 71
episodes yeah I don't think they were
expecting people to know which ones like
you were saying that it comes out if we
hadn't done this and talked about it is
really subtle well stealth the way they
did it well when it first happened and
those episodes originally a couple
months ago were taken over during the
original transfer between Spotify
between YouTube and Spotify it was the
most controversial episodes that were
missing and accidentally not ported over
which left a lot of people asking some
serious questions that of course Warren
answered we also have to understand this
is on the heels of the US government the
Biden Administration putting pressure on
Spotify British royalty putting pressure
on uh of course Spotify the same British
royalty that has connections and things
with like individuals like Jeffrey
Epstein and and all these other
individuals so so we're having a lot of
very powerful institutions whether
BlackRock or Pfizer or the US government
or all these other big Financial players
and multinational corporations saying
stop exposing the agenda stop destroying
the narrative we need to have our way
with the general public you informing
them giving people informed consent and
having people think critically about
what we're doing to them is not helping
us you better stop right now and this is
an effort of of of it being stopped
here's what I want to say though he
didn't take Dr Malone down he didn't
take McCullough down I wonder if this
might be Joe saying okay in these
episodes I may have crossed the line if
I take these ones down it protects my
ability to do shows in the future now
hold on that being said these videos
taking them down solves nothing they
still exist they're all archived when
the First episodes got pulled people in
Mass archived all of his shows there's
literally no point in pulling these
videos down the clips are already out
there the criticism is already out there
the shows have already existed for a
decade I don't see what the logical
reason is for removing anything I don't
think Joe did this I think he would be a
lot smarter because even if he did do
what you explained he would have done it
in a transparent way where he would have
made an announcement and said hey I need
to be a better person or whatever or
dress or dress it doing it on a Friday
night doing it I I think it could either
be some Rogue Spotify employees because
there was previous accusations of Rogue
Spotify employees leaking private
information and of course course having
a vendetta against Joe Rogan it could be
Spotify crumbling it could be Spotify
sending a message it could have been an
error who knows we don't know exactly
what's happening here we're just
speculating and it's important to
understand that there has been a
tremendous amount of pressure put on Joe
Rogan and he doesn't just represent a
podcast he's not just an MMA guy that
likes to talk about chimpanzees he
represents critical thinking he
represents thought being expressed by
questions uh and
for him to be taken down it's crazy what
a reality what a timeline we're in
coming off of the Donald Trump
presidency the leader of the Free World
leading the charge on critical thinking
the guy from Fear Factor Joe Rogan live
with Theo Vaughn who had a contest that
made people drink special juices from
horses for fifty thousand dollars they
said that comedians were like the the
truth tellers of our age and I never
really truly understood it until about
three years ago yeah absolutely yeah
good point make that point again because
that's an important point that you just
made the comedians are the truth tellers
of our age and there have been like I
think Voltaire said if you're going to
tell people the truth make sure you make
them laugh or they'll kill you yeah it's
just so true absolutely that's a very
good good point you brought even
powerful militant Elite authoritarians
want to laugh they're human you know and
they they love comedy
um Bin Laden played uh Final Fantasy VII
I wanna just we'll wrap this segment up
with a couple points uh I I reached out
uh to Joe just you know yo what up he
hasn't gone back to me he has no
obligation to get back to me I don't
want to uh
you know abuse the fact that I know him
to to get private information like
anything like that if he if he can't
talk about it well you know
unfortunately then he can't but I don't
know maybe he'll message me back say I
was working out or something so I will
say
it's it's really really good that his
show exists I mean it's it's really
really important the Malone episode is
still up the reason we're all like we
are what's going on is because we
recognize how important his show is and
it's worrying to see that episodes are
getting pulled down we we need to be
able to cut through the BS and outside
of Joe it's it's important to mention
that the mainstream narrative the
mainstream media they're tumbling they
are fumbling they're falling apart we
got this story from Yahoo news January 6
committee lawmakers devastated by Jeff
zucker's ouster from CNN this one's just
a really amazing story
because apparently CNN employees are
freaking out that Jeff Zucker gets get
you know get he gets basically ousted
the new guy who's apparently in one of
the largest shareholders and I think
it's called Uh from Liberty Media which
is the largest shareholder in Discovery
Discovery who is then taking over CNN is
a large Trump donor so the top level CNN
staff are all freaking out and they're
saying in these meetings that I've
spoken with the January four members of
the January 6th committee and they're
devastated this is happening why are
they devastated because we learned from
Rolling Stone that at the highest levels
of CNN they were colluding with Andrew
Cuomo a Democrat Governor to help him
craft his covid narrative they were
talking about this guy being a
presidential candidate at the time and
CNN was helping him Kris Cuomo was
helping his brother and I think that's
why the whole Scandal erupts Chris Cuomo
helps his brother knows zucker's helping
his brother then when he gets busted
Zucker says you're fired Chris Cuomo
goes you were doing the same thing and
he's like too bad and he's like well
then pay me out my contract and zucker's
like I ain't paying you out your
contract and then Chris says I will oust
I will get you fired I will I will tell
everybody about your relationship with
this woman and then he does and now the
whole thing's imploding and falling
apart but you know what we see from this
it's uh it's becoming clear and clear
out in the open in the mainstream press
CNN was colluding with democrats for
favorable press coverage we always knew
it because it was obvious to anyone who
paid attention but now it's definitive
and in print we can see it that's that's
why they want to censor everybody else
so they can get away with stuff like
that my conspiracy senses are tingling
because I definitely do not believe that
Zucker went down because of an affair
that people knew about for years Katie
Couric was even talking about I think
there's something bigger at play here
and I think there is some kind of
Vengeance from the Comas the comos are a
very powerful family politically
especially decades and decades ago
especially with the power that they had
in New York and the the political sphere
a long time ago but uh when it comes to
CNN obviously people are realizing this
is not journalism this is not news this
is PR for special interests special
interest pay them support them and they
do their bidding no matter what and
they're willing to cross any line
they're willing to violate any kind of
Morality In order to help the people
that pay them and this is essentially
the big business of corporate media
that's exactly what it is it's nothing
else it's not even media it's propaganda
could it be a could it be that the
alcidum because of some flights he took
to a certain Island
we don't know if Zucker was uh I haven't
seen any direct uh evidence about that
but I wouldn't be surprised if that was
the case I'd not heard that he had been
on those planes no no I haven't heard it
either but it's got it no I think this
is more you're right more than just an
affair yeah I think it's that they were
colluding with Democrats the the most
trusted Naaman news working with
democrats for favorable coverage is a
massive probably one of the biggest
media scandals or there could be a
bigger Story coming out about their
direct involvement
um that they're trying to of course save
face on and to of course not get a big
backlash on and that's why they're
stepping down preemptively there could
be something even bigger coming to light
soon but why would the uh I know that
you still have to finish reading it but
why would the January 6 committee
uh be devastated because is basically
their mouthpiece they're trying to come
out with this lie they've they've
they're trying to come out they've been
screaming the lie for a year about
January 6. it's quite simple January 6
was bad a lot of people fought their way
through that front tunnel and fought
with cops fought their way in the front
of the Capitol really really bad bad
Riot a lot of these people had the doors
opened for them by the police CNN wants
to push the Insurrection narrative
because they are helping Democrats they
are now being exposed their own
president colluding with Democrats the
woman is having an affair with worked
for Cuomo so when they come out and
they're like it was an Insurrection and
then you get these Democrats saying
we're going to file a lawsuit because
anyone who spoke at that rally was
involved in Insurrection is no longer
eligible to be a public official
CNN is helping them do that and they got
caught
that's why and that's why they're
devastated they're like oh no our whole
mission to to defraud the American
people well they're the whole narrative
depends on the mouthpieces CNN is the
mouthpiece of their narrative that
they've been pushing and obsessing about
to the point where they have been losing
90 of Their audience they have been
working so hard at doing the bidding of
the special interest that they're losing
everyone and and it's not a surprise why
people don't watch them why people don't
trust them because it's it's clearer
than ever they're not in the business of
news they're in the business of power
and I think uh I think you would agree
with Me Enrique that the January 6th
panel is about power as well no no it's
about truth they're trying they're
trying to find out what happened January
6. yep man yeah it's really it's really
crazy to watch this past month how the
establishment seems to be collapsing at
an exponential exponentially increasing
rate
yep and are are we does this mean that
we're going to see now um because this
would be complete Twilight Zone we're
gonna see more right wing CNN now this
is crazy because apparently this guy
John Malone I think his name is he owns
his company called Liberty Media I think
fact check man this one I think it's
called Liberty Media I think that's what
he owns and they're like a quarter 25
shareholder of Discovery Discovery is
basically buying Time Warner or
something like that like Warner media
which owns CNN so ultimately you get
this dude who apparently he's been very
critical of Jeff Zucker he said he wants
CNN to be impartial this was three years
ago
now he's going to have some of the
biggest uh the most voting power in the
company that basically owns CNN and a
lot of people are speculating now
it's going to go either like middle of
the road or center right or something I
I doubt it I think that with the staff
that they've hired they've already
created that culture within their Halls
um within the whole culture within CNN
um and I think that what's going to
happen is you're going to see I don't
know I don't know if they're like Union
eyes or whatever but you're gonna see
like a big push if if he wants to take
in that direction I I I disagree there
there's the Veritas release where
there's this like this producer guy and
he's like I remember when we were would
report the news now it's just all Trump
all day I mean there are people who work
there who are upset that they work at
this job that's become this trash in
this private meeting you had people like
Jake Tapper Jake Tapper said if it
wasn't for Zucker the network would have
become benign vanilla gruel what's the
news supposed to be chocolate sprinkles
no it's supposed to be benign vanilla
gruel it's supposed to be your it's
supposed to be your vegetables you know
when I was a kid
Seinfeld and The Simpsons that was
dessert but the but the but the
vegetables was the news it was like you
this is your five o'clock news on Fox 32
and it was boring and I was like nah and
then as soon as it ended the Simpsons
came out I was like all right The
Simpsons what do they think CNN is
supposed to be it's supposed to be news
but Zucker is a reality TV guy a deeply
deeply evil man who turned politics in
this country into a spectacle for profit
and he destroyed the network there's
another story from the rap private text
messages from former employees of CNN
saying Zucker destroyed the network and
he did and now that he's leaving Jim
Acosta I think it was said we would be
something like Fox News light Fox News
light does that mean Centrist yo because
it's probably what's CNN support like
should have been wasn't there a Fox news
reporter that like quit live on air
Fox news reporter I don't know yeah I
think you've had her on the show Ivory
hacker yeah oh yeah that was Fox local
yeah that was stunning I hope more
people do what she did because yeah
because they told her that they didn't
want to report stories because certain
racial groups didn't care about these
stories I think she wanted to report on
bitcoin was that what it was I don't
remember this details of it I think it
was something like that and they were
like you know this particular racial
group doesn't care about that so we're
not going to report it and it's like
well you know to be honest I understand
the point they're making we run a
business but at the same time if your
news is predicated upon what you can
sell to the masses you become CNN and
that is a problem it's a fine line but
you know the we used to have a news or
maybe we never did maybe we never did
yeah this independent journalism I think
is the way it's supposed to be what we
got now like we are change and Tim cast
and stuff well that's I mean that's the
future that's less people are tuning in
to mainstream media more people are
tuning in to like podcasts alternative
media
um and I think it's just going to get
worse and I think these networks are
gonna are gonna suffer the problem is
with Independent Media is how do you
verify they're not a crackpot is that's
challenging you kind of got to like peer
review them no no you just you just have
to only watch the shows where people
speak a certain way like they talk like
this if they speak like this and you
know when referring to what happened in
Liechtenstein that's like another
credible and they have suits and they
have paychecks from uh Bill Gates then
they're 100 incredible and absolutely
true but but if they talk like this guys
really fast like okay gang you know we
gotta talk about what's going on two
risks no yeah you can't trust them I'll
enjoy the Anarchy yeah but but Ian to
answer your question what Independent
Media does what Joe Rogan does
especially with his long format three
hour long conversations which from any
kind of business perspective if you
would have asked a media guy like is
this going to be successful they would
say no but why is it successful is
because you're taking along a journey of
experiencing and exploring and finding
things out not through an agenda or a
narrative or something that has already
has uh you know a final plan of what you
think it is it's an exploration so when
we have an independent media we have
sharing of data of information and
conversations and debates that you would
never have on the corporate media that
question everything in our reality and
that's why it's so much better and
stronger than the corporate media trash
that they feed and shove down our
throats you see a while back people
started complaining that the news was
turning everything into sound bites that
instead of talking about politics it was
just a five minute clip on the TV then
Twitter comes along and there's this
video Glenn Greenwald shared from 09
where he said I think it's a problem
that Twitter has his character limit and
it's going to keep you know reducing our
conversations and and making it you know
making it worse off
now what's happened we've we've we've
punched that that rubber you know he
stretched that rubber band to the point
where I can't go any further and snapped
back and now we've gone from the two
minute sound bite to the three hour long
form podcast conversation as the media
choice for so many people so CNN they're
Old Guard their you know Fox News
they're like Tim would you like to come
on the show we'll give you two minutes
and I'm like nah no thanks dude worse
Jordan Peterson was four and a half
hours on Rogan this last one and it was
totally fine I only saw the first 40
minutes so far I was driving it was
already in Florida I watched all of it
and it was amazing so who's to say how
long is it going to go it might not even
matter at this point like length maybe
isn't the the problem it's authenticity
and an ability to flesh out ideas so
people can wrap their minds around it
instead of a guy coming out and being
like antifa is bad and uh vote Trump bye
like you know hold on let's slow down
and say you know you've got people then
saying yeah but Trump is bad no no we
get that like when you have long-form
conversations you can say things like it
was bad that Trump from Syria but it was
good that Trump tried to get our troops
out of Afghanistan and set the deadline
for the withdrawal and then Joe Biden
flubbed it you can get into all the
details around it and the nuances the
true the truth is nuanced right it's not
black and white there's a lot of gray
there's a lot of exploration there's a
lot of things that you have to come to
an understanding of by patiently hearing
both sides of the story the only way you
could do that is through of course long
formats instead of two-minute segments
but let's let's meet and potatoes you
know when I do when and I've had a lot
of times where like uh these networks
are like hey why don't you come on and
it's two minutes and it always if it's a
right-wing Outlet it's always the same
thing tell me who the proud boys are
tell me how you a man of color can be a
white supremacist it's the same like
there's there's no there's no there's no
time for me to get into it that's and I
think a lot of people and we should be
happy that people want those that long
for uh format for media because that
means that just people want more they
want more information and they want to
establish these arguments too because I
I listened to I listen to stuff like I
listen to right-wing things just to get
like a different perspective on like
other what other people are thinking I
also watch left wing podcasts I do watch
CNN I do read CNN so we we talked about
uh the media the manipulation but I want
to talk about the physical actions
they're being taken get into what
happened with you so the first thing I
want to ask you Enrique atario uh uh are
you still are you still involved with
the proud boys yes I'm still involved
with the proud boys but more at a local
level I uh Wednesday I stepped down as a
chairman of the organization after about
three and a half almost four years are
you in any way involved with law
enforcement
is there more to that question are you
affected no the simple answer is no that
story came from let me ask you go ahead
have you ever done any work with law
enforcement yes
yes I have when okay so uh one I worked
with the dodo as a contractor for DOD
but that doesn't count really what
people want to know is the FBI
involvement in 2012 I got arrested and
yes I helped the FBI bust a human
trafficking ring coming into the U.S
um and then the third thing is
most recently working with law
enforcement
everybody's waiting patiently
um is when we go to these rallies and we
go to like Portland DC or Austin you
know these big blue cities where antifa
comes in wants to
wreak havoc before we get there we
contact law enforcement we call the cops
if we're getting if we're getting
threats from out of the state yes we'll
contact the FBI because that was the
only people that could do anything about
it
um and that wasn't a secret it was never
a secret so when the story came out
everybody's like oh well we got you I'm
like you've never watched my podcast
I've been talking about this for years
it's not a secret
um they uh I've heard the conspiracy
theories in in the context of the
political conflict over the past several
years have you ever provided information
or testimony to law enforcement to Aid
in the prosecution of an individual
absolutely not not even antifa
I've sent yes okay yes and that is yes
what about the humanities I've said
documents in the context of the conflict
yes so we have sent information whenever
we've gotten credible threats or we see
threats on Twitter we've exposed who
that person is and yes we have forwarded
it uh over I mean we we put a white
house that's overt right like you're
you're publicly acknowledging you're
doing these things but in secret have
you you know spoken with law enforcement
so that it could assist them in the in
the arrest or prosecution of of you know
anybody involved in these protests
absolutely not
all right well Absolutely I'll just say
this for everybody who who's not a fan
of you yeah that they can believe what
they want to believe if they want to
believe you're an informant that's their
I'm okay with it is there anything else
you could tell us more about the the dod
or the trafficking case because that
seems something that's the dod was I
basically did uh security cameras and I
did security assessments and I would do
it for you know military bases
um Lockheed Martin Boeing and those
companies and I also did it for retail
stores large retail stores like Macy's
um so that wasn't I mean that's not here
nor there and then the human trafficking
ring did come from Mexico uh they were
trafficking women right uh it was a sex
trade and you know guilty I gave them
that and if people like like Tim said I
I've been dealing this for about a year
I don't care if somebody loves me or
hates me for that story I'm gonna say my
truth and if you accept it you accept it
if you don't you don't
um
that's not my problem I bust a ring of
human traffickers but that you feel
guilty for having done that or you feel
like people are gonna say hey bad on you
for helping the FBI I mean I'm not going
to tell you I'm proud of it either I
think that's a good thing you did I mean
I'm not going to tell you I'm proud of
it or or I feel guilty for it but I am
going to tell you I just
this is my truth and either you accept
it or you don't well let's talk about
where people get suspicious so uh what
was it January 4th January 4th you got
you got stopped and arrested in DC yes
and so so what happened
um so to know what happened January 4th
you got to go back to December 12th on
December 12th there was a banner that
was burnt a BLM Banner
um that came off of a church which I
didn't know it came off a church and on
December 13th the Metropolitan Police
Department and the FBI Washington field
office uh put some pictures up a proud
boys that weren't even in the area
um and said we're looking for these
individuals because we're investigating
a hate crime now if people don't know
even if it's a misdemeanor if there's a
hate crime modifier that could put you
years in jail I don't know if you guys
heard the the person that pulled down
the rainbow flag and burned it they gave
him 15 years okay so the very next day
on my podcast live I admitted to burning
that Banner and also on my parlor I
admitted to burning it
um
there was a warrant out for my arrest
shortly after that I knew going into DC
that I'd be arrested I knew it that's
why I flew January 4th because DC is a
no bail State I'd be let out on January
5th and then I could go I can go watch
the president speak at that time
obviously remember we didn't know that
uh the capital was going to be breached
or anything like that we just wanted to
have a good time and see the president
speak and get trashed like we usually do
um so I flew into DC my number one
mistake is I put I sell uh magazines uh
laser engraved magazines on my website
and I did bring two empty magazines not
pistols like a lot of people
um have accused me of
um
I get arrested they didn't know about
the magazines I have a simple
uh under 500 misdemeanor destruction of
property I leave DC uh DC uh DCA Ronald
Reagan and they wait till they were
following me the moment that I got out
of the gate of the airport and uh yeah
after they landed after I landed uh
where did you land in DCA oh okay and
uh I I got in an Uber and I was driving
into DC
and I mean they came to get me like I
was Noriega for a misdemeanor again they
didn't know anything about the magazines
even though the magazines by themselves
aren't really dangerous
uh the whole they had a whole SRT team
ARS pointing at the Uber
um there was a there was a news cam the
crazy part about this and I swear to you
there's a news camera full-size news
camera pointing at
um at this everything that was going on
I haven't seen that footage yet
but um was it CNN or I don't know okay I
don't know I I don't doubt it's CNN
because you saw the the stone story when
they came to get stoned CNN was
magically in the corner of his house
uh he lives on a dead end street by the
way at that time
um
and I think what they wanted to do is
two things
I think what they wanted to do is send a
message to anybody that was coming to
town that day
and the second thing that they uh we're
trying to do is I think they were trying
to take me out of the equation
because
I'll tell you this
if I was on the ground in DC on January
6
proud boys wouldn't have been arrested I
wouldn't let any of them go inside I
would have seen it from a mile away
didn't The Oath Keepers guy say the same
thing like he told him not to go in and
they went in anyway I I don't know much
about like The Oath Keepers case I
haven't read his uh latest indictment I
know that Stewart was on like Capitol
grounds
um when that happened do you think he's
a Fed
uh well they hit him with if they're
hitting a Fed with seditious conspiracy
charges so that he can plead the fifth
and won't testify because the defense
teams wanted these guys to testify in
their defense and now they won't and the
j6 and the j6 committee are you talking
for the cases for these cases one of the
things that uh that people are concerned
with is
they have this guy's Communications for
a year they don't charge them and that
and and uh I don't know if it was him
specifically but there's been other
cases where as soon as the defense says
like we want this person to testify in
under defense they go oh we're charging
him and now he pleads the fifth Tim I
find it weird
but I've been on the end where people
have called me a Fed for the past year
like right now and yeah probably on your
live chat no uh Luke and I were called
feds endlessly back you know Luke
probably still gets called the FED all
the time and
I just like I've been on I've been on
that side for a year so I can't tell you
if he is or isn't I haven't really
looked into it much but I could tell you
that everybody gets called a Fed at some
point and it's inevitable and I think
it's by Design you know you see like
cointel Pro you know how do you America
is not going to die by murder America is
going to die by Suicide now put that in
a microscope and put it into groups
groups like The Proud boys aren't going
to die because because of anything but
internal turmoil and we've we've we've
had those we've had internal turmoil
from from the beginning so we're used to
it we're a completely different group
but
um let's hear that wind coming through I
hear that is that rain I don't know it
sounds awesome though that's soothing oh
your fan I was like what was that oh but
anyway uh you know one of the one of the
reasons people think that you're a Fed
is that they feel like you got pulled
out they they they they stopped you from
being there on January 6 to make sure
you were out of The Fray and not
involved in any of it you're in jail
convenient at least we have a perfect
Alibi and
I understand that concern I get it and
it's it is a really good argument oh
they pulled you out so his their asset
wouldn't be there
but then like a judge gives me five
months for pleading out to a misdemeanor
they give me Max sentence I'm currently
on probation I gotta do three years
probation on it uh I'm not gonna say
anything on on live right now but you
know anybody that was there on December
12th knows what happened
and
I just think that
it's meant to divide us it's meant we're
very United right now but they're trying
to divide us they're trying to make us
fight with each other they're trying to
cause this internal turmoil and I think
now is not the time again I I'm just
gonna say my story if people accept it
they do but I'm speaking in general I
think that we need to get together and
we need to focus because we're going to
lose everything is jail like is
isolation like mind breaking is it like
psychosis inducing if you're and I'm not
gonna say if you're a weak-minded
individual like anybody could be broken
I'll tell you it was
and I was only there for a short time I
don't want to sound like I'm complaining
because some of these guys have been
there for over a year
you know
um but I was there for five months short
uh the first
the wind the wind on the window the
first two weeks was extremely difficult
um because it was straight isolation you
know I come straight from the street I'm
a very social person I'm around my
family all the time and they put me they
put me in a six by four
and they lock you in for 23 hours a day
and at the beginning I was considered
high profile so they have me on like
this Hannibal Lecter program so when
they let me out for an hour they don't
let me out with anybody else I would
walk the track which is an indoor track
with no no windows I'd walk the track
alone and it reminds me of that Meme
using that Meme of uh of um
uh damn it what's that guy from Colombia
the the drug lord yeah yeah
you've seen those Escobar memes where
he's just sitting on like the bench or
he has his hand that's what it reminded
me of because I'm like damn I must look
like a freaking crazy person walking
around here but it was the only exercise
I'd got but I continued through that
isolation
um
for the next three months after the two
weeks I calmed down a little bit I have
my books I was reading Non-Stop and uh
you know we're putting I was in there
with some of the j6 defendants and we're
putting in Grievances and shortly after
that Marshals came in did an inspection
found the place unlivable
why was it like like toilets were
backing up and spilling all over or
something I mean there's a lot of things
like I could go on I could go on like
two hours just about that alone but it
starts off with like medical right
um
over treatment under treatment it
started out my first experience is like
some guy was having some type of medical
issue where he passed out next to like
my cell right it took them 20 minutes to
come pick up this guy and he was
unresponsive I don't know what happened
to this guy
um I know that I was uh I had problems
sleeping when the doctor came by and I'm
like hey I have a problem sleeping and
the next day they come with like a
little thing with like five different
pills they're like you have anxiety I'm
like you know what I'm just not gonna
take this there was three people that
OD'd in my unit
within 24 hours from the medic from the
medicine they gave him well uh yes
because they would smoke it was crazy
they'd smoke like some type of pill and
then they'd mix it with like K2
and then the more the more severe things
were you know your water would be turned
off for three days you couldn't flush
the toilet you couldn't use the sink
there was no hot water for for anything
except for a shower
um
there was multiple times where like
people would flood and there's like
this crap there's little crap [ __ ] in
the water about an inch and you're it's
it's flooded inside your cell and they'd
leave it in there for like two days
they wouldn't let you out you know
because it's flooded they wouldn't let
you out they'd cut off your water and
then they try to give you water and bags
and there was like
24 hours that you wouldn't get one of
those little bags and when you get it
you know you're like
uh drinking it up
um abuses from uh the guards were
prevalent especially with the j6
protesters
um while I was in there
um
I mean attorney client privilege doesn't
exist they did not denied me from seeing
my attorney multiple times and the one
of the times that they did they put me
in a hallway
right with two guards next to us no
walls in between us there was no sense
of privacy you know we're talking about
you know I'm being sued it's it's a war
of attrition they put me in jail
the j6 committee subpoenas me I wasn't
in I wasn't even in DC at the time uh
I'm being sued by members of Congress
I'm being sued by Capital police I'm
being sued by the DC government I'm
being sued by a church
for what so well for January 6. but I
wasn't there I'm sorry I wasn't there
the church that's suing me is doesn't
even wasn't the church that the banner
was burned from it's another church
somewhere else I don't even know where
this church is so what they're trying to
do is they're trying to break me down
they're trying to expose me as an FBI
informant so my own guys turn on me uh
they're trying to hit me financially
which they already have a long time ago
so they could sue me and be like you owe
us a hundred billion dollars and I'll be
like cool I'll send you like some shirts
because I literally I'm broke was there
an effort you just mentioned a little
bit that they tried to make you look
like an informant is there more that you
could tell us about that I think what
they did is they got those three
portions of the story I made earlier the
the Contracting for the dod uh the stuff
from 2012 and me us how was that
released because that usually especially
when it comes to like confidential
informance that stuff usually isn't
released right that's the other thing
that's crazy is that that's not really
supposed to be released but
um like who released that and how did
that his name is
um Aaron Roston with Reuters
um and he released a story and he mixed
in a whole bunch of things in there just
to kind of like give it some spunk
um I honestly believe right now Aaron
rossen is uh they're leaking information
from the j6 committee uh to Aaron Roston
um at the time but that's a whole other
ball game
um
but
what we're seeing here is they want to
Def they want it to de-platform you
because it's things that we were talking
about years ago they want to de-finance
you they want to sue you take everything
that you got they want to put you in a
cage and eventually what they want is
they want you dead
okay and I'm not I'm not exaggerating
here that's that's the road that we're
going on
I always think about how they would try
and get like they'd try and torture
someone to admit that they lied right
before they execute them back like
really horrible totalitarian governments
they like get them on stage in front of
everyone they're like now tell them all
that you were lying the whole time
they're like no no and they're beating
them tell them tell them and then they
finally say okay I was lying they're
like good and then they kill them that's
the tactic that they're using with some
of these j6 defendants what they're
doing is these people some of these
people aren't accused with being violent
right some of these excuse aren't
accused of like stealing or breaking
anything no assaults no nothing you know
they just walked in and out and they've
been in jail for a year and basically
what they're trying to do and they keep
them in that 23-1 lockdown for a year
you know I don't care how strong you are
they get they they put you they put you
in solitary confinement and that
lockdown for long enough your mind's not
going to come all well you've got fried
not gonna be fried that's torture that's
what happened to Chelsea Manning that's
what's happening to Julian Assange who
should not be in jail right now who
hasn't been convicted of any crime he's
facing charges here in the United States
was just crazy but correct me if I'm
wrong it was the CI confidential
informant uh information is that correct
that's correct I remember seeing that
and wondering this is supposed to be
classified this is supposed to be kept
away from the general public this is not
supposed to be known there are no public
releases about this kind of information
because it's it's held secretly so
people don't know the kind of means and
techniques of of was it uh the the
Federal Bureau Investigation or was it a
local police department yeah FBI so so
they don't usually release that
information uh especially with such a
high profile case because it actually
puts the case in Jeopardy doesn't it
well here's here's the the kicker on
that article I don't know if that's what
you're watching right now on that
article this journalist I've never heard
this I've never heard this before
besides being able to get these records
he was able to get the judge to give
comment on the case and the
ex-prosecutor on the case
um to give comment on on what happened
on those proceedings right
so I think that that's why I honestly
think that that story
um was timed to to cause turmoil
no I think that's what they wanted to do
now you made a statement about your
truth what is your truth
on what uh you've made a statement uh
before when we were talking about this
saying this is my Truth uh specifically
with you know all the accusations and
sure I just kind of wanted to ask you an
open-ended generalized question what is
your truth my truth is uh
I've I can't cuss here
I've screwed up many times in my life
I'm not a perfect person like some
people put me on like this pedestal as
like this person that you should follow
I'm not the most moral person in the
world
okay and I've screwed up I'm not proud
of what happened in 2012 but I did it
but the truth is now there is no truth
to hey you're working with the feds
right and again that story just doesn't
bother me anymore I love my Bros I love
my family
I before jail if I was on this show I
tell you I love my country I can't tell
you that anymore
I can't my priorities have changed since
I've gone in I love the Constitution but
I love this fascist thing I I don't I
can't I can't tell you my priorities
were my God my family my country now
it's my God my family my tribe and to me
what that tribe is is people that do
believe in that document people that do
want to better this country and to me
those people are more important than
a set of borders what are some of the
names of the people that are in prison
right now these January 6th are there
any names uh there's actually many names
um there's Charles Donahoe right we call
them yacht uh Zachary Rel
an Nordeen uh also known as Rufio
um Joe Biggs
um we have dude we have like 26 guys
that are that are arrested
um
and you know can I say can I say hey did
they deserve something I'm like well you
trespassed fine hit him with trespassing
but that's not what they're getting hit
with that's why I'm fighting well hold
on a minute is it trespassing if the
police open the door yes no I agree with
that I'm just telling you like let me
let me let me just say because we had we
had an incident recently where a guy
trespassed on the property and the
reason it was trespassing is because we
have two very large
signs of very large signs one of them is
no trespassing this is private property
everything you do is being filmed if you
keep going another sign a smaller one
says you are now trespassing on private
property
when we talked to the police they said
if someone crosses a barricade in any
way
after having trespassed it's burglary in
Maryland
if you don't have any notification or
signs no crime has been committed yeah
so when it came to the capitol A lot of
people keep saying trespassing and I
think it's because we're like you know
they they entered this this property but
the capital is public property my
understanding is that many of these
buildings I'm not sure about the capital
specifically are open to the public in
most cases and for a lot of these people
you can watch video of the police
opening up the door and saying I agree
with your right to protest so these
people who walked in and were looking
around and like smiling and waving they
were not informed they weren't allowed
to be there there were no signs there's
no warning the first thing that has to
happen is excuse me you are trespassing
during an official proceeding you need
to leave oh sorry about that bye-bye but
they didn't do that so I'm wondering if
this is even trespassing well here's the
thing so and the reason why I say is not
convicted of trespassing I think that
that should be like the most the the
most serious of charges to somebody that
did an assault or break anything right
but uh in legalese uh the trespassing
charge that they're charged with isn't
even applicable because it goes a step
further to the no signs thing so the
building in in the in the law it states
that the building must be secured by
Secret Service the version of
trespassing that they're hit with and
the building's not secured by the Secret
Service the building's secured by
Capital police but
what I'm fighting at I'm not fighting
I'm not saying they have to fight that
misdemeanor if they get it but they're
we're way past that
they're using this archaic law called
obstructing an official proceeding
because it's the only felony that they
could be charged with the only felony
that they could be charged with is
obstructing an official proceeding and
it doesn't apply in this setting because
it's meant for like witness tampering
it's not meant for like protesting and
obstructing an official proceeding at
all and as a matter of fact what was
happening January 6 isn't an official
proceeding at all it is a ceremonial
proceeding so if January 6th let's say
everybody got coveted right and nobody
showed up to the January 6th the
certification of the election still
happens Joe Biden is still inaugurated
president uh in 2020 Congress has no say
in how the states vote for a candidate
voting that's a whole other issue I'm
not going to get into that but when
we're talking about the certification
it's not an official proceeding but
they're using it because it's like the
only thing that this government's like
this government said we got to give them
decades and what do they do they keep
them in the gulag right they keep them
in the gulag for a year locked up and
they're like whoa you're facing decades
and then the first prosecutor that comes
in and gives them a deal it's like well
you know what we're going to give you
six or seven years like
you're stuck in this hole and you're
like okay you know what I gotta take
this deal I gotta take this deal and it
makes you like it makes you not want to
fight these cases right because you're
scared they broke you and it's so easy
to get to that point how can we help
those people
um
I know that there's uh there's a couple
of uh what I'll do is if if you guys
follow my telegram Channel I'll post it
but I know that there's some channels on
telegram that are uh constantly posting
um fundraisers ways to contact these
people something that helped me that was
great uh I got a lot of mail I got to
read a lot of mail uh people send me
books I got to read a lot of books
um and then obviously the fundraisers if
we if anybody can help any of the j6ers
period
um by fundraising there's also uh as far
as the proud boys go there's a channel
on telegram called app free the proud
boys and it has like the contact
information on how you can write to them
uh and things like that like a lot of
those people I imagine they have
families and they're out of work now so
the family is suffering financially as a
result yeah and then maybe can be people
can donate to their families directly
that's that's that's another thing
that's on there is like a lot of family
funds
um where you can go ahead and uh and you
know give there's Amazon list too we got
to go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com if you want to help support
the work we do and all of our
journalists and get your super jets in
we're going to read a bunch of what you
got all right we got Marcus a Lundy says
listen to Will of the people yesterday
and I have to ask where the hell did
that voice come from 1010 download and
we'll listen again thank you very much
good sir yeah uh for those that may be
new to the show we used to do Jam
sessions on Friday nights I have been uh
playing music since I was like seven
years old drums Guitar vocals we're
working on a bunch of new songs we got
Ian jamming on a lot of these songs oh
man we're working with Pete Parada
formerly of The Offspring doing drums
for a bunch of our songs really really
uh it is an honor and a privilege and
hopefully we can get Mr Phil Labonte of
All That Remains he expressed interest
in collaborating on a song that would be
amazing and if you haven't already you
can check out will of the people on
YouTube it's a video on this channel and
it is my music video about the cycle of
Revenge violence and revolution
all right let's see what we got Andre
says give send to go crashed from all
the traffic honk yep yep all right Hong
Kong
all right all right
chance says Tim you should build Culture
by making a 2A show like demo Ranch I'd
pay extra for it and would let you use
my Arsenal to get it started we've
actually discussed doing that but uh we
wanted we want to build do more than
just you know hey we're on a ranch and
we're gonna blow stuff up because it's
been done and so we're something better
than that yeah well I mean I like the
idea yeah I do like that idea
you got to figure out your angle you
know do it from above maybe that angle
top down maybe we can find a way to uh
we got we got to check the laws on this
one but you know drone work with like
you know demolition drones if we could
like zoom in really fast into an
explosion in slow motion that'd be cool
and back out really fast in slow motion
one of the things we did on one of the
Vlogs was when we were at the shooting
range after we fired we had a camera on
the side of uh one of the guns one of
the rifles and then we had the Drone
after we were done we had the Drone fly
forward like it was you know like it was
the bullet so we just like boom with the
Drone stuff like that so you know we'll
see we'll see yeah
Quagsire says I've been thinking about
that Starship Troopers quote for the
past week with all the news about the
Convoy when you said it my face lit up
honk Hong Kong which quote uh when
Doogie Howser puts his hand on the alien
it does it's afraid and they're like
yeah
what a what a what a truly amazing piece
of literature
the Starship Troopers yeah you guys have
you guys I'm just watching us watch
actually two days ago the movie doesn't
do the book Justice my understanding is
I think Carl Benjamin did a breakdown of
like the book is actually a lot better
the guy who made the movie tried to
wanted to make them fascist I've been
thinking about it because I was telling
you guys how I kill the stink bugs I
throw them outside into their cold death
and it makes me think about the bugs
from Starship Troopers and how they
weren't evil or good they were just bugs
just living and the humans made them out
to seem evil because that was the humans
were the fascists because because the
aliens launched A Primitive attack so we
were told yeah no I mean I think humans
were the preemptive in the story it's so
you're you're getting the Starship
Trooper story from an omniscient
perspective the bugs attacked Earth
first and then Earth responded and the
guy who made the movie tried to make it
seem like the humans were the fascists
like we're talking about they blew
Buenos Aires dude I don't know good
story good story huh couple of
authorities was it service guaranteed
citizenship yep all right Brandis
Brandon Tom says I wonder which charity
GoFundMe will donate to BLM Planned
Parenthood maybe a little bit of both
yeah maybe to act blue how about that
thanks for all your money
all right let's see we got
Chris Christopher Chavez says so I've
just watched YouTube not allow me to
call out one of their paid shills I
tried posting a reply three times and
each time I went to check the reply
wasn't there that has never happened to
me before you know um I feel like I run
a risk by even mentioning this but um
we've done it before and I'll do it
again there's something what's it called
the 50 Cent Army and what they do is in
China like whenever someone a regular
citizen posts Pro CCP propaganda they
get 50 cents or something like that we
did an episode where I mentioned this
and like right so there's a delay when
we talk about a minute 30 seconds to a
minute after I say it it appears on
YouTube there's that lag right and so
during the show we kept getting a drop
off like the show would pause and then
jump and then after the show people were
like oh they were weird skips you know
at certain points and then it turns out
whenever we mentioned the 50 Cent Army
the show would drop for a few seconds
I'm watching it right now seeing if it's
dropping but I don't think it is I mean
maybe it was just a coincidence yeah you
know maybe it's a coincidence and we're
all just paranoid or whatever but I
thought that was funny
so yeah there I'm I'm also wasn't it
also that you couldn't post some kind of
like offensive Chinese slur
yeah there was a slur for like a Chinese
Communist and like YouTube would delete
it if you posted it yeah I'm pretty I'm
wondering like did China already win the
war you know looks like it I don't know
I'm encouraged when people say what a
paper tiger that government is yeah
that's a benison that you baby what does
what say what sorry my eyes are bad
uh I don't know I don't know Justin
Bookman says hello Tim and crew Ian is a
fellow ohioan so I would hang out at
Walmart after school but I feel I feel
like there are times at 8am in Tim's
kitchen where you're going about the
going going on about the FED but Tim is
like I just want to know if you want
syrup on your pancakes Tim's lives on
the other side of the house now we used
to pop in and say hi to each other once
in a while during the day but you sleep
until yeah nowadays 6 p.m I think it's
about to change I'm pretty excited about
it with what just uh my schedule I want
to be up during the day oh yeah yeah
that night yeah no more sleeping at
night let's get a little more active yep
all right let's grab some super chats
Haywood says they are creating
extremists one blue collar worker at a
time maybe that's what they want they
want they want to beat down regular
people to the point where they can use
them as propaganda that's why I always
say non-violent Civil Disobedience Works
violence does not work we are not in the
16 or 1700s anymore or even the 1800s
and people say yo but antifa gets away
with it yes because they get funding
from the state literally Illinois
Democratic Administration was giving BLM
money it was from the state these people
are on the side of the fascists so let
me make something very very simple for
all you guys
pulling up in your car and honking your
horn
is destroying the establishment they're
screaming and and freaking out and it is
the most amazing joyful positive and
peaceful protest you see non-violence of
disobedience is the key they don't know
what to do they're like well they're
violent and it's like a granny is
handing out muffins and they're like but
they're racist and then there's like one
guy with a Confederate flag non-violent
civil disobedience is working
and that one guy gets kicked out of the
protest it's working and I don't know
what to do about it I wouldn't say the
Confederate flag's not a racist thing is
it is it being Twisted to be racist
nowadays I mean yeah but first the
Confederate flag it's the Battle Flag
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna nitpick
when someone's like I think that's Flack
that's a racist flag I'll be like man I
get it you know I understand that's not
the point the point is the truckers
aren't racist the regular working-class
people you know I think they're not
violent they're peaceful and the
establishment doesn't know what to do
yeah like this guy said they're making
what do they say radical truckers one
day at a time or something blue collar
workers new co-workers I don't think
that this established order understands
that it's creating the collateral damage
of blue collar extremism like same as
bombing Middle East and killing parents
and the kids grow up and become
extremists they weren't intending they
want more January 6. they want regular
working people to lose their minds so
they can justify Banning people from
Congress and seizing control but when
people just stand around and dance they
don't know what to do if you if you
silence somebody if you definance them
if you take everything from them and
then you demonize them
do you think that that person is going
to rationalize or do you think that that
person is going to be radicalized yeah
exactly like people aren't going to go
oh okay you know what
you're silencing me you're calling me
names I'm broke you know what maybe I'm
wrong that's not gonna happen
I don't care it's not gonna happen
it's a conversation I've had with a
really good friend of mine about
platforming people he's like you're
directly contributing to the rise on a
fascist state of the United States by
platform people like you for instance
because of our conversation but first of
all he doesn't know who you are he's
just heard your name he heard the media
reports and like dude if you try and
stifle people especially people you
don't agree with and force them
underground they don't go away and the
ideology doesn't disappear yeah it goes
into the corner and festers and rots and
grows I think what the reason the real
reason why people hate me is I'm really
really good at making fun of people
like I got a knack for it I don't think
people understand know who you are
enough to hate you it doesn't that's
true it's true of Rogan these people
have not watched any of his episodes no
let's read some more we got flick off
says if you guys get Dan Crenshaw on
please ask him about being one of the
cloud one of Klaus Schwab's young global
leaders would also like to hear Luke's
opinion on it I actually have a
statement on this first the first thing
is we were supposed to have Dan
yesterday but they had to vote and so it
went all night but he did reschedule I'm
uh I'm grateful that he wants to come on
the show I look forward to talking to
him and he he already responded to me
about this he said that he had nothing
to do I'm paraphrasing but basically
the world economic Forum creates their
own editorial list like Forbes 30 under
30. they decide to just highlight people
they think are prominent figures and he
had nothing to do with it and now
because they put his name on it everyone
thinks he's involved with the world
economic Forum which he's not well
people are concerned because there's the
video going around right now that I
tweeted myself from Klaus Schwab in 2017
literally bragging about how he claims
to penetrate the Canadian government the
Argentinian government the French
government and how half of the cabinet
members of the Trudeau government are
from the world economic Forum so because
of that people are you know triggered
and concerned about people being
associated with it and and that's why I
was really looking forward to that
conversation I think you know Dan should
either disavow or publicly say that he
does not want to be a part of that list
and say and ask them to take them off I
so when I when when I was talking to him
to ask him to come on the show he meant
come come on the show he mentioned that
he's like he's like dude I had nothing
to do that's great let them make a
statement and saying I don't agree with
the world economic Forum I don't agree
with their Vision this is what I
personally think yeah and if that would
have happened I think that would have
been very important and I think a lot of
people would have respected that and and
especially if they could get an honest
point of view of where he stands on this
very powerful organization that has
mobilized the corporate world the
government World towards creating a
great reset what's his ideas about the
great reset what's his ideas about the
2030 vision would love to hear about it
and uh you know hopefully this
conversations penetrating
dude I would have loved to be here Dan
was here previous dude this this
Austrian old Austrian Authority
authorocrat this corporatist like it's
such a bond villain I know it comes up a
lot that Clash Royale is like doesn't he
look like a boss it looks like him
sounds like him he's like Dr Evil he's
trying to corporatize the global
government I mean it's it's what a bond
villain would do it's incredible and and
yes I am peeling an orange right now in
the middle of super chats yeah I'm sorry
Luke brought all these Origins
brought them here for everyone and I get
I get attacked because of it do you see
the hospitality here I'm from Florida
and this orange is from Idaho oh
the size of that thing GMO oh my gosh
that's probably genetics yeah you guys
ever see you ever see these blood
oranges man they're so good look at this
I'm what I'm gonna try and stop doing is
eating non-organic food like genetically
modified food or stuff with antibiotics
and stuff no you're not gonna eat that
I'm gonna try and avoid it at all costs
like good luck especially animal
products that have been injected with
hormones and well let's let's listen
stuff let's read some more Super chats
though I want to make sure we're giving
to people Rick Hunter says Enrique has
been disavowed take your colors off no
great have you been to Savannah I have
not been disavowed I've been the
opposite of this about
but yeah I'm actually surprised that in
the super chats I've only gotten one of
those comments all right just Revenant
says hey Luke is Alex Jones Bill Hicks
that's this
uh
exactly
he loves it yeah all the time he's like
it's crazy but we had him here and I
asked him and actually I accidentally
said Bill Burr so it's like are you Bill
Burr he's like what no and then I was
like oh Bill Hicks yeah I cannot expose
such big truths does he say it's a
conspiracy theory
yeah yeah oh you know what Alex admits
it yeah conspiracy theory no Alex is I I
think people need to understand a lot of
his show is like sensationalized and I
don't mean that he's not I I'm not
saying like he I think he's putting on a
show is what I mean to say and if when
you actually talk to him he can very
calmly break you down like break down
these stories and walk from point A to
point B for you but I gotta admit when
he goes on Joe Rogan and he's like human
animal hybrids and and you know they're
building these 5G Towers when he came on
the show the first time he was telling
us about Klaus Schwab is the first time
I ever heard about Cloud Schwab and he
also mentioned Klaus and another guy
together and I don't remember the other
guy's name but we gotta figure that out
because he was just as intertwined as
Klaus and all this it was more than just
Klaus I want to pin it on him Alex comes
on the show with philabonte and uh and
I'm like let's talk about immigration
and then within 30 seconds Alex is like
so so when Thomas Jefferson was ruled
was running the Illuminati all right
George Washington's right and then I'm
like Phil help and he goes yeah
I'm like what are you doing it's
supposed to be helping control this uh
it was fun though he's really smart he
is he's Alex very very like he remembers
dates uh numbers people dates of birth
uh the guy's a walking encyclopedia I
love him yeah he's great
all right let's read some super chats we
got Vision Quest he says spending our
Friday evening watching timcast IRL on
on one TV and Viva Fry on another thank
you both for doing what you do so well
could use another honest journalist up
there Luke
I don't have a good relationship with
the Canadians 10 years yeah I got banned
10 years for um
um false pretenses I was arrested
falsely by Mayor Bloomberg in New York
City uh all the charges were dropped but
as soon as I came up to the border the
Canadian mounties stopped me
interrogated me uh went through all of
my devices went through all of my
clothing every little piece of thing
they tore everything apart had dogs all
over my place and then they told me that
I was a criminal I was arrested and I
have a criminal record according to the
FBI which I never had I've been arrested
a number of times never found guilty
arrested seven times uh always charges
dropped because it was always for the
crimes of Journalism and asking people
hard questions and they said I was
convicted when I never was so you were
you were banned for 10 years banned for
10 years they're like don't come back in
Canada for 10 years then got a lawyer I
fought it and I was actually able to go
to Canada within the seventh year that's
actually super cute I've been banned
from Canada for life and I've never
stepped foot in the country wow for a
while I see someone oh God Canada
designated the proud boys a domestic
terrorist group over there and the
Canadian proud boys never even go out to
like rallies
uh so I'm banned completely for Life wow
I can't never go there and I've never
been there not that I want to go there
although I do want to go support these
truckers but let's read some some more
Super chats we got zorark he says a Joe
fan here I'm losing faith in him after
CNN defamed him he wouldn't sue them
because Jeff was his friend now we are
missing more episodes I'm starting to
think he isn't on the side of freedom I
completely disagree with that uh
I certainly think Joe is one of the most
important individuals fighting for free
thought and freedom and he defended his
podcast with Malone and Peter McCullough
and I respect that greatly and um let's
be real like when Joe had me on the show
the first and second times he he helped
Lift Me Up tremendously so whatever you
think about what he's doing now whatever
whatever you want you want to be
critical of him absolutely that's why
we'll still talk about what's going on
with this show that's why I'll still
question what's happening with the show
no free passes but Joe has been such an
amazing net positive for freedom in this
country I just think you gotta you gotta
just his show is fantastic it's one of
the most important things keep the faith
man Joe's a good dude you got to judge
people by the fruit of their labors and
when you look at the fruit produced by
Joe Rogan holy cow there's been a lot of
counter narratives there's been a lot of
information that the very powerful
people are trying to keep away from you
you got a crazy obsession with fruits
yeah look at the size of that thing yeah
I think I bear many fruits Rogan didn't
say he didn't sue CNN because he was
friends with Zucker he mentioned that he
was friends with Zucker while he was
talking about it I think he just he
never said why he wasn't going to sue
them why honestly I think Joe's trying
to de-escalate to a great degree but
he's but I also think he's a bit
abstinent he refuses just toe he I I
don't think he's the kind of guy who
just wants to lie you know so when they
when Sanjay Gupta comes on he's like no
like dude you guys lied about me but you
know when Sanjay Gupta wrote that
article and said I was afraid Joe Rogan
was going to jump the table and throttle
my neck when I brought that up to Joe he
was like ah he's just trying to be funny
man and I'm like I I don't give him the
benefit of the doubt the way you do you
know I just
sure maybe is there some humor in that
but you know the reason that plays well
to the left is because they believe it
they believe you're the guy who's what
what did Ethan Klein say that he's like
hopped up on human growth hormone and
stuff like that like they're insulting
you so Joe's not stupid I think he knows
all of this but I think he's trying to
avoid escalating a conflict with them I
think Joe uh when he put out that
statement and he was like yeah I'm sorry
for pissing you guys off I'll do better
next time very very well played because
it's hard to look like the bad guy when
you're being nice and making jokes and
saying you're a fan of Neil Young and
all that and then even the rock
apparently comes out and he's like rock
on brother so you want you want to be
the nice guy there was a there was a hit
piece that was written about him and
this guy was like I started watching
several episodes and it came across one
with Joe Rogan and Tim Poole and he
refers to me in like I forgot what he
said about me he said that I was like
um
an extremist but uh I forgot what word
he used basically that I'm it's like
passionate but in a negative way
whatever he was saying that I'm like
partisan and you know hyper focused and
um you know to a degree like I forgot
yeah you'll think of it I know what
you're talking about but he was he was
basically saying that I was fervent you
know that I was like ah and Joe is much
more like well calm down there buddy and
you know and I think that's Joe's that's
how that's how he plays it you know he
wants to have on people like Josh Epps
you know that's the guy who claimed that
the uh in tournament camps in Australia
were just international arrival
Bungalows oh and then they started
taking people from their homes and
bringing them to there which makes it an
internment camp at the very least like
the most modest definition
so Joe will have him on and just be like
okay you know you know he made me look
bad and you know I I love the guy so
thank you and he's very very polite
about it I think that's his play yeah I
get the whole wanting to get along with
everybody and wanting to smooth it over
and kind of be like the penultimate
Diplomat but also if you see somebody
torturing somebody else like if it's
your brother that's getting tortured
like you kind of gotta not be a diplomat
anymore now it's time to take action
well Joe did Joe did end up defending me
on on two occasions from that guy's
insults though so it's like you know
look I I think Joe's a good dude I'm
eternally grateful for him having me on
his show because it like I gained like
300 000 subscribers the first time I
went on a show it was nuts then he
invites me on to meet with Jack Dorsey
and I I told him on the phone I was like
I was like Joe uh I'll do this show but
I'm like a little baby bird and you're
kicking me out of the nest here buddy
like I was like I've got like a hundred
I got like 180 000 subscribers on
YouTube and you're asking me to go have
a conversation with the CEO and like the
chief legal for the one of the biggest
companies in the world and he was like
you're smart guy dude you can do this
and I was like I was like I'm not scared
I'm just like ass on that one I was like
all right let's do it I I didn't prepare
I was just like I don't know man I'm a
guy I'm gonna sit in chair I'm gonna
talk about stuff but uh uh dude uh the
the dude's a he's a good guy and and he
and and I'll tell you this when we all
got sick Joe uh covered the cost for us
on on our treatments and he was just
like he's like I appreciate you coming
to my show man so look I'm not gonna I'm
never gonna be someone who's gonna give
free passes to anybody I want to know
why those episodes got pulled down
because I think his show is so important
I think he's a good dude
if Joe has some kind of privacy issue or
business issue and he can't tell me I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna cry or complain
about it I trust him I trust that he's
going to do that he's going to do the
right thing and I think he's proven that
by having Dr Malone on his show so just
hopefully we we have the faith we remain
critical when we need to be but Joe's
one of the good ones man keep the faith
he's got an amazing show and he's a good
dude and he took care of us that's right
yeah man so thank you seriously
all right and we got this one from kui
matters Eastern Europe knows about Joe
Rogan and anyone not bought and anyone
that isn't mentally ill sees that as
sees this as a power grab and it always
starts with the U.S Greetings From
Beyond the Iron Curtain well hello there
the FCB says fedcast IRL somebody
somebody
no no somebody in the chat said Luke is
a Fed oh oh
[Laughter]
you guys you guys got to pump those
numbers up on them oh two to one right
now during it's embarrassing you know
what I get I get tons of people saying
like how does Tim fund this show this is
insane I've seen a bunch of comments
where they're like how does Tim have
that building this doesn't make sense
his channel is not that big and I'm like
I don't think people realize how
business works and we have a website and
we have memberships and we sell merch
and we you know all that stuff I always
get asked how do you how do you make all
this money to fly everywhere I'm like
what do you think I don't work for a
living
apparently not we're like plane tickets
can be 70 bucks if you fly Regional and
small not only that I live in M.I.A
which is like the cheapest airport in
the country I go to Colorado round trip
for 60 bucks nice yeah my flight here
was like a hundred bucks yeah so great
all right miklos says Tim Shadow Banning
is a thing if I wouldn't be subbed and
notified I wouldn't get your content and
that's true and you know what's really
frustrating several times on this show
I've been like oh I want to pull up this
Instagram post from from Sargon Carl
Benjamin and I go on Instagram and I
type in his name and it doesn't come up
yeah and I'm like I follow the guy okay
and Instagram doesn't show me his
account and then I have to like manually
go to a browser and type it in because
if you I like I go to search I type in
Carl Benjamin I type in his username
100. it won't come up I'm like how am I
supposed to go to his profile so I go to
my own follower list my own following
list and I scroll through until I find
the accounts I'm following it and then I
go in yo Shadow Bannings it's real and
it's insane
all right we've got a couple more
fleshy Javelin good name says Tim I was
a national Guardsman in DC from the
start of covet all through the riots and
the other side's incident and I would
love to talk about it send an email to
spintheufo gmail.com
Lydia will look for the email from
fleshy Javelin sounds great there you go
forward to that one great name also with
the super chat before it's not just
Shadow batting it's also Instagram
saying don't follow this person he
spreads dangerous misinformation as they
did to me a few weeks ago and they're
doing it now to imagine nois I don't
know crazy I don't know what Instagram
Facebook or YouTube looks like anymore I
have no idea and I haven't known for
three years man all right you're not
missing out no no Roadrunner says Ian
rolled higher on the die today be safe
Enrique I brought my dice up here just
to wait what is that supposed to expect
so yeah there's a there's this
philosophy that when I ever played
Dungeons and Dragons no when you when
you play Dungeons dragons you make an
action I'm gonna attack that Goblin you
roll a 20 sided die and if you the
higher you get the better if you get a
20 it's a critical success you hit no
matter what if you get a one it's a
critical failure you miss no matter what
so when I talk on the show I tend to
either roll a 20 with my ideas or a one
because it's what will happen is I'll
swing for the fences and if it's if I
see that it's not going I just give up
he's the Wild Card keep swinging I'll
keep swinging Luke I love you baby
sometimes he's like we'll be talking
about you know the politics of Ukraine
and The Invasion and then Ian will be
like start thinking about the north did
you ever did you ever put your finger in
a cow's mouth
because I'll be thinking about Ukraine
from the 70s where a guy a farmer was
talking about the cows and then we're
all laughing like what but then
sometimes we'll be talking about covet
and stuff and then he'll roll a 20 and
be like how do we balance people's
freedoms with more serious diseases like
Ebola when you have a very high
mortality rate and to me good question
to me
you always roll a 20. right back at you
I love your glasses by the way thank you
I have obsidian dice that's what I want
to show off
all right we'll read a couple more here
we got uh justice says I found Tim pool
throat through Joe Rogan and many other
people that are relevant now no Luke I
puke that's right damn right yeah man uh
Joe's gonna have a lasting impact
because he's been he has so many people
on his show and ends up
like it's kind of crazy that these ideas
of freedom and inquiry are spreading
because of this one show is is you know
great shouting everybody out you know I
want to not put too much pressure on Joe
because his show is really the guests I
mean he's a big part of that obviously
he's a big part of it but his guess man
the knowledge that comes out of that
shows from the guests and he just kind
of lets it come out of them yeah it is
but
you listen to his show you know he's
talking and he has these ideas and she
asks his questions and he's he's created
that centralized hub for all of this
stuff that's why it works we also can't
just depend on him for everything and we
need to decentralize this whole
Independent Media sphere so we only
aren't just focusing on him he's great
he's amazing but he's also a big Target
we need a lot more targets out there to
make sure that he doesn't get taken down
we just got to keep doing the work we do
we got to keep growing we got to keep
getting more support over at timcast.com
from from everybody and help us get
bigger and bigger and uh you know we do
we we have a different kind of format
here it's not too too dissimilar though
but we have various guests on uh and
Shout out right now to Viva fry
obviously on the ground reporting live
from the trucker protest he also has a a
YouTube channel where he does uh legal
analysis so uh channels like Viva are
awesome we had him on the show super
cool what were you saying
I started talking to him yeah
no it's crazy
my friends if you haven't already
smashed that like button subscribe to
the channel share the show with your
friends if you really want to help out
if you want to support us directly go to
timcast.com become a member you can
follow the show at timcastirl everywhere
you can follow us on Instagram for Clips
you can follow me personally at timcast
everywhere and especially on Instagram
Enrique you want to shout anything out
um so the only place that you could find
me right now is telegram if uh you could
just go to your browser hit T dot me
slash Noble leader is that is that the
one that works or if you got your
telegram app just hit the at sign Noble
leader and that is my channel where you
can keep up to dates on my podcasts and
news about the j6 political prisoners
yep definitely uh nothing is safe on the
internet but telegram is one of the
safest places sort of out there still
somewhat of an okay place to talk I
think my channel is at news the number
four uh a change I think that's it I'm
not sure but one of the other best ways
to communicate is through email since of
course I get to keep the emails no
centralized big tech company gets to
keep it and if you want sign up on my
email list on enough of censorship.com I
am going to be doing in real life
meetups which only you could find out
about on enough of censorship.com hope
to see you there I got a lot of very
exciting projects coming up and I hope
to have your participation in it and I
should be going back to Florida pretty
much in a few hours oh it's going to be
there bye everyone I'm Ian cross on
follow me Ian crossland.net if you want
to link into my socials Enrique I'm in
I'm in and one more thing that I'd like
to say I'm really really upset that I
was only called the FED twice
at all okay good there was there was
much more in the chat don't worry I was
just going to say every time I make a
thumbnail with Joe Rogan in it first of
all it does incredibly well because
people really care about Joe Rogan and
second of all I'm just reminded of how
important he is and I never thought that
I'd live in a world where a former MMA
fighter UFC commentator and comedian is
one of the most important ones we have
but he is just because he does ask
questions and he gives platform to all
kinds of different voices I really
appreciate it you never thought MMO no
no no no no he didn't he fought in the
MMA he was going to own Wesley Snipes he
never fought he was going to do that for
like a celebrity match right no but he
was young it was Taekwondo I I misplaced
I met UFC never fought in the UFC I just
want to say you know it gets to a
certain point where I'm like dude are we
really talking about Joe again like
kickboxing it's no I mean this story
won't stop and it's really weird you
know especially knowing Joe I'm like I
don't want to keep talking about that
yeah I don't want to put too much
pressure on him it's not about pressure
on him it's just like but I thought
about it and with all of these news
stories constantly getting bigger I
realized I think Joe is actually more
important influential and powerful than
even I realized yes it feels weird to
talk about this dude who does a podcast
Until you realize it's the it's probably
the biggest show in the world yeah and
you've got the president of Brazil
talking about it it would be like me
saying oh I don't want to report on CNN
because you know I know people who work
there or something it's like no we got
to talk about it well we've said it
before that Joe Rogan does dictate the
news cycle and he definitely does and
I'm very happy to see it to me it
definitely does look like the last death
battle of a Dying um media conglomerate
anyway you guys can follow me on Twitter
at sour patchless and minds.com as well
thanks so much for hanging out go to
timcast.com become a member enjoy your
weekend ladies and gentlemen we are
going to have a nice send-off party for
Luke for the second time because we did
the first time it was great went to a
steakhouse and uh we will see you all at
youtube.com cast castle in the Vlog
tomorrow morning and then we'll be back
with the show on Monday thanks for
hanging out bye guys